Good morning. Seeing that the board members are now present, Brooks, will you please call
the roll to establish a quorum? Yes, good morning. Member Rodriguez.
Could you hear me? Present.
Harding now. Thank you so much. Member Fetillo-Brownson.
Good morning. Member McQuillan.
Here. Member Orozco-Gonzalez.
Present. Member Olken.
Present. Member Lewis.
Present. Vice President Glover-Woods.
Here. Member Escobedo.
Here. President Darling-Hammond.
Here. Member Bonacca.
Here. Everyone's present.
Wonderful. I hereby call the March 2022 Meeting of the State Board of Education to
order at 8 31 a.m. And I'd like to start by polluting the flag. And Member Glover-Woods,
would you please lead us in the Pledge of Allegiance? Yes, I would be honored to. Good
morning. Please join me as we say the Pledge of Allegiance. Ready, begin. I pledge allegiance
to the flag of the United States of America and to the Republic for which it stands, one nation
under God, indivisible, with liberty and justice for all.
Thank you so much.
We are now going to welcome three new board members and I will administer the oath of
office to each of them. And I'm going to begin with Gabriela Orozco-Gonzalez.
And so if you can raise your right hand. My hand is up, you know, with this background,
it sometimes disappears. And please repeat after me. I, Gabriela.
I, Gabriela. Orozco-Gonzalez.
Do solemnly swear. Do solemnly swear.
That I will support and defend the Constitution of the United States.
Against all enemies, foreign and domestic. Against all enemies, foreign and domestic.
That I will bear true faith and allegiance to the Constitution of the United States.
That I'll bear true faith and allegiance to the Constitution of the United States.
And the Constitution of the State of California.
And the Constitution of the State of California. That I take this obligation freely.
That I take this obligation freely.
Without any mental reservation or purpose of evasion.
And that I will well and faithfully discharge
the duties upon which I am about to enter.
That I will freely, oh, please repeat that part.
And that I will well and faithfully discharge.
That I will well and faithfully discharge.
The duties upon which I am about to enter.
The duties which I'm about to enter.
Wonderful.
Thank you, Gabriella.
Thank you.
Yay.
And I'm going to now move to Brenda Lewis.
Brenda, if you could raise your right hand.
And of course, with the background,
you have to put it up close enough to be seen, right?
Hi, Brenda Lewis.
Oh, you're, yes.
Sorry.
Hi, Brenda Lewis.
Do solemnly swear.
That I will support and defend
the Constitution of the United States.
Against all enemies, foreign and domestic.
That I will bear true faith and allegiance
to the Constitution of the United States.
And the Constitution of California.
and the Constitution of California,
that I take this obligation freely,
without any mental reservation or purpose of evasion,
and that I will well and faithfully discharge,
and I will well and faithfully discharge,
the duties upon which I am about to enter,
the duties upon which I am about to enter.
Thank you so much, Brenda.
Welcome to the board.
Thank you.
All right, and next, Sharon Olken.
Sharon, please raise your right hand and repeat after me.
I, Sharon Olken.
Do solemnly swear.
That I will support and defend
the Constitution of the United States.
Against all enemies, foreign and domestic.
That I will bear true faith and allegiance
to the Constitution of the United States.
And the Constitution of the State of California.
That I take this obligation freely.
on any mental reservation or purpose of evasion.
Without any mental reservation or purpose of evasion.
And that I will well and faithfully discharge the duties.
Upon which I am about to enter.
Thank you, Sharon.
Welcome to the board.
It's wonderful to have you all on board.
And I'd like to ask each of the new board members
if they'd like to share a few introductory comments
beginning with Sharon Elkin.
You fooled me, backwards order there.
I know, we do this, we go back and forth.
They don't make it funny to feel like, you know,
they're at the end of the alphabet and always last, so.
Thank you.
Well, I just first want to say,
I'm so honored and excited to be joining this group.
And saying that oath of office really brought it home.
What a important and public duty this is.
I mean, I'm honored.
And I have been working on behalf of the students
at Gateway for the last 20 plus years.
And I've always felt like my job
was both to do right by our kids
and by the kids across all public schools more broadly.
And I'm really thankful to have this opportunity
to step up in this way and to join you
and learn from you all.
So thank you for this honor and I'm happy to be here.
I just want to say one more thing.
I'm super excited to roll up my sleeves and get to work.
And unfortunately, I am going to miss the rest of today
because of a family funeral I need to attend.
So I will really roll up my sleeves tomorrow, bye.
Our hearts go with you this afternoon
and we're thrilled to welcome you this morning.
Thank you.
Brenda.
Okay, I knew with that L, there was no fooling me.
I'm in the middle, either way we go.
But first of all, good morning again to each of you.
And like Sharon, I am truly excited and honored
to be a member of this board.
And I am truly looking forward to working with each of you
and other stakeholders as we just continue to make sure
that we ensure a good academic environment in our schools
for our students and an environment that has supported
measures for our students,
as well as great working environments for our teachers
and for our other staff members.
And again, like Sharon, I am truly just honored
to be able to serve at this capacity and at this level.
And I look forward to working with each of you.
I've spent the last 33 years in education
within one district,
and it was an honor to serve over 40,000 students.
And now it's an honor to serve the millions of students
and teachers and staff in California.
So again, I'm just grateful for the opportunity.
Thank you.
6.2 million children.
Millions.
Yeah, that's a millions.
Thank you.
Well, thank you again for this honor
to be part of this board and this team.
I look forward to collaborating.
It's been a dream of mine since I was a little girl
to become a teacher from being an instructional assistant,
working with bilingual children to becoming a teacher
and just looking at actually different educational systems
all over the world.
I've been an avid traveler
and it's always been a passion of mine
and to work not only in this great state of California,
but also to work in an urban school and school district.
It really is a pleasure to be part of this team,
to collaborate and be able to share my ideas,
not only my personal experiences
as an English language learner,
but as a teacher that has worked
for over 20 years in urban settings.
So I'm excited to also dive in to learn and to collaborate
and just to share my ideas
and hopefully contribute as much as I can to the board
and to our students, six million.
And that alone is exciting and it drives me every day.
So thank you so much.
Great to have you here.
What a wonderful start to the day.
And so now we're gonna go into closed session.
So board members, please disconnect from this link,
go to the closed session Zoom link.
And then when we come back, we'll use this link again.
So we'll see you in closed session.
Linda, just before we depart,
would you like to announce what we're gonna discuss
in closed session?
Oh, okay, yes.
We'll be discussing EE versus state
and Cary K versus state in closed session.
All right, welcome back everyone.
Seeing that the board members are now present.
Brooks, will you please call the roll to establish a quorum?
Take two.
We're hearing you.
We're not seeing you, but we're hearing you.
Hearing means all that matters.
Okay, can you please call the roll?
Member Bonacca.
Here.
President Darlene Hammond.
Member Escobedo.
Here.
Vice President Glover-Woods.
Member Lewis.
Present.
Member McQuillan.
Here.
Member Oaken.
Member Orozco-Gonzalez.
Here.
Member Petillo-Brownson.
Member Rodriguez.
Present.
We have a quorum.
Okay, seeing in closed session,
the board discussed and took action
on the following legal matters,
EE versus state and Cary K versus state.
In terms of general announcements,
there is one public hearing on the agenda.
Item 11, EGLE Collegiate Academy,
which we will hold a public hearing
and consider revocation of the charter
pursuant to California Education Code Section 47607H.
The proposed regular consent items
are items eight through 10,
which will be taken up later this afternoon.
The proposed waiver consent items are W1 through eight,
which will be taken up tomorrow morning.
Changes in the agenda include taking up item four,
the accountability item after the state superintendent
and the state board president's reports under item one.
The state board pulled item seven from the agenda
on Monday, March 7th.
Tomorrow we will reopen item one
to take action on the January 2022 minutes
and to take up the state board liaison reports.
Members of the public who are wishing
to call in for public comment
should view the live stream of the meeting
to know at what time public comment
will occur for each item.
Public comment may be provided by dialing the phone number
and entering a participant access code
on a slide that we will display
and then following each of the operator's prompts.
Upon dialing in, the callers will be added to the caller queue.
The operator will notify callers
when it is their turn to provide public comment.
We will also ask callers to please turn down
the speaker volume of their computers.
If they're following the live webcast
to avoid an echoing effect.
Public comment will be limited to one minute per speaker.
Item 13 is the general public comment item
during which members of the public
may provide comment on matters
that are not specifically listed on the board's agenda.
Board members, please mute your microphones
when not speaking and keep your cameras on at all times
except during the scheduled breaks
or if you need to take a momentary break
to ensure that we maintain a quorum
throughout today's virtual meeting.
For each item on the agenda,
there will be an opportunity for you to raise your hand
using the Zoom participant window
if you would like to ask a question or make a comment.
And item one where we will start
is our State Board projects and priorities item
and I'll now turn it over to State Superintendent
Tony Thurman for his remarks.
And I'm looking for the State Superintendent on my screen.
President Darling-Hammond,
we're just pulling up the cameras here for the podium.
Okay, great.
Thank you, President Darling-Hammond,
members of the board, good morning
to the new members of the board.
We'd like to welcome you to the board
and we look forward to our work with you.
We'd like to share just a few notes
about items taking place in schools
and about work happening
at the California Department of Education.
I'll note that on last week,
we helped many of our schools celebrate
Read Across America Day
and I'll note that in this year's proposed budget,
the governor has made programs
to support literacy a priority.
In particular, supporting reading coaches and specialists,
an item that we think is very important
to support the needs of our students.
I wanna thank you, President Darling-Hammond
for your support of that item
and for your work with our reading
by third grade task force
which also had similar recommendations.
It was great to be out at Jordan Academy
and have an opportunity to read with students
for Read Across America Day.
This is the location that I've been able to visit
over the last four years and all across our state.
Our students and our educators
have been engaged in literacy.
We intend to continue supporting it.
Many of you know that the Department of Education
this year is sponsoring a bill
that would expand funding for literacy programs
in the form of home visiting outreach
to support our families.
Additionally, the Department of Education
is supporting legislation that would allocate new funding
to support literacy intervention programs
like the Freedom Schools Program
which is a evidence-based program,
an Afrocentric literacy intervention program.
We're making and continuing to make literacy
among our top priorities to support California students.
I also wanna speak on a program that's related
and equally important
and that is the Community Schools Initiative.
As many of you remember and recall,
the budget has a $3 billion allocation
to implement a Community Schools Initiative.
I wanna thank the board for its involvement here
and our board liaisons,
President Darling-Hammond and Dr. Escobedo
who've been our board liaisons on community schools.
And thank you for all of your great work.
The request for application has gone out
on March 1st for planning grants.
These are grants that help school districts
that have never had a Community Schools Initiative
launch one, do the planning work
to determine how to build it.
We're anticipating that this week
a round of grant applications will go out
for school districts that will be applying
for implementation grants
to implement a Community Schools Initiative.
These are for school districts
that actually have experience working with community schools
and so that they have an opportunity
to further launch their work.
And shortly after, we anticipate next week
that there'll be another round
of grant applications going out
for those organizations that want
to become lead technical assistance agencies
to provide guidance to our school districts
as it relates to community schools.
So we're happy to answer questions
from members of the board at any time
about community schools.
We just wanted to give you the update
that the work is moving.
The legislature and the state board
have made it a priority
that these community schools resources
get to schools as quickly as can be possible.
And so we wanted to keep you aware
where things are with these programs.
The report from our schools,
they're doing incredible work
and we continue to commend all educators,
teachers and classified staff,
administrators, students and parents
for their resilience during these challenging times.
Our schools are open and our children are learning
and we're grateful for the efforts
of those who are supporting them.
In spite of challenges that we experience in our system,
like staffing shortages,
our schools are finding ways
to make the most with the resources that we have.
And so we commend them for their work.
Many of you know that we have launched a working group
that is focused on addressing staff shortages.
We've had a number of meetings to look at the data
to examine where educators are going
and why they're leaving.
They will not surprise you,
especially given the research
that our president has done over the years,
that compensation and working conditions
are certainly among top issues
for why educators leave the field at every level.
Of course, these departures have been exaggerated
and exacerbated by the pandemic.
We've just seen that in education,
like in every sector, many folks are leaving.
But we believe that there is an opportunity
to attract new folks to the profession
and to help retain those who are in the profession
and that we need a call to action
to remind educator candidates
that this is an incredible opportunity
to help young people.
This state has more than $350 million
in residency programs that districts can use.
The state has provided five billion-some dollars
for educator effectiveness grants
being administered through the Department of Education
and our Triple ED division and incredible work there.
This state also makes some $500 million available
in scholarships for new applicants
who wish to become teachers.
The resources are here.
We just have to find ways to link together
those resources in coordination and recruitment.
There are many items in the governor's proposed budget
that would enhance the work of the Commission
on Teacher Credentialing to support some of that recruitment
and we continue to work with organizations
that are interested in how to recruit and retain
a great workforce and a diverse workforce,
which is something that we continue to prioritize.
I would acknowledge that on last week,
the Department of Public Health made a formal announcement
about wearing masks in schools
and that as of the end of this week,
by March 11th, the mandate for wearing masks in schools
will have been lifted.
Of course, masks can still be worn in schools.
It continues to be recommended, but after this Friday,
our schools have been presented with information
that the mandate to wear a mask has been lifted.
Recognizing that there's been tremendous success
that has allowed us to get to this place.
Californians are highly vaccinated.
The fact that California has used masks
and other health protocols has allowed us
to keep our schools open more than most other states.
I would still urge caution because we recognize
that there are many communities
where vaccine rates are still low
and many communities where incidents
of coronavirus infection are still high,
not the least of which are the African American community
and in some cases, Latino community
and Asian American Pacific Islander communities.
And we should still be cautious.
And so for clarity for schools,
the mask mandate has been lifted,
but masks are still recommended
as well as other health and safety protocols
that can be provided for our schools.
Lots of great things happening
to support our schools going forward.
We know that our students will recover
in terms of learning gaps that they've experienced
during the pandemic.
Universal TK programs and implementation efforts
are underway.
We wanna acknowledge the great work
of our early learning and care division
who are at the head of this.
Universal meals, this week I had the opportunity
to celebrate what was the kickoff
of national school breakfast week
and many campaigns being supported,
including by our first partner in the state
to support organic meals, organic breakfast
and organic cereal.
Again, wanna harken that this budget
that we are currently implementing
provides revenue to have universal meals
for all students, two meals,
regardless of a student's background,
that we are implementing programs
to help school districts upgrade their school facilities.
And I would note some $47 million
for schools for fresh fruit and other organic foods.
And so lots of things in the works
to support our schools.
There is a Children's Behavioral Health Initiative,
more than $4.3 billion to support mental health.
We're working closely with the Departments
of Public Health and Health Care Services
on how this moves forward.
We've introduced at the Department of Legislation,
sponsored legislation rather,
would help to fill out the pathways
of those who'd become mental health professionals.
SB 1229 would provide scholarships
to those who would become masters level clinicians
and commit to working in communities of high need.
By most accounts, California, even before the pandemic
was only able to provide about a third of the need
for those who needed a mental health professional.
We know that's been exacerbated by the pandemic,
by the 25 counties that have experienced fire.
So we've introduced SB 1229,
a bill that would fund scholarships
for those who would enter graduate programs
to become clinicians and work in schools.
And we anticipate that this revenue could help
to secure 10,000 new mental health clinicians
for our schools over the course of the next several years.
The Department of Education is currently working
to administer grants that can also support
student mental health needs,
including a grant to help school districts
counter social isolation,
as well as an effort where the Department of Education
will provide technical assistance to school districts
to help them learn how to utilize Medi-Cal dollars
to draw down federal dollars
to support the delivery of mental health programs.
And finally, I would mention
that the California Department of Education
will be putting out a request for proposals
that focuses on efforts to address bias in our schools.
This is a $10 million initiative
funded in last year's budget,
being implemented by the department
to address the issues related to bias
and racism in our schools.
There's no shortage of things happening
that I believe will help to transform California schools.
We like to lift these up, our community schools,
our statewide mental health initiative, our anti-bias work,
our work around universal TK and universal meals,
and of course, expanded learning
to provide the types of resources
to help our students heal from the trauma of the pandemic,
recover as it relates to their learning,
and to thrive as we move to help them prepare for the future.
And so I'm happy to share these updates, Madam President.
And Madam President,
if you would allow me just one more opportunity,
I'd like to take a moment of personal privilege
to acknowledge a long-time CDE employee
who has now joined the ranks officially
of the State Board of Education.
With your permission, Madam President.
Please go right ahead.
Thank you. I'd like to acknowledge Lisa Constancio,
a 25-year employee of the state of California
who doesn't know that this is happening.
But nonetheless, we want to acknowledge Lisa,
who is in the State Boardroom.
I think she's trying to exit the State Boardroom.
And so I have to acknowledge her this way
so that we do not lose her.
Lisa has served at the Department of Education
for 15 years until recently,
and she's joined the team at the State Board of Education.
We're grateful for 25 years of state service
and 15 years at CDE,
and that as she has departed and begun her new duties
in January of this year,
that she's literally just gone down the hallway
and still in the building,
maybe still in the same parking lot,
and that we still have the opportunity
to work closely with her.
For those of you who don't know Lisa Constancio,
if I can just share a little bit about the work
that she's done at the California Department of Education.
She has served in many capacities
since joining the department in 2006.
In 2017, she became the division director
for our charter school's division.
And I had the good fortune to work closely with her in 2019
when the governor appointed the task force
on charter school reform,
which made the first reform of charter school law in decades.
And that task force came up with balanced recommendations
to address many needs,
and Lisa played an integral part in that work.
Lisa went on to become appointed to serve
as deputy superintendent at the Department of Education,
working with a number of our divisions
that address a number of fiscal issues.
And in addition to that, during the pandemic,
Lisa became our point person for many of the efforts
focused on dealing with response to emergencies
and natural disasters.
She became a regular member of the meetings
with the Office of Emergency Services,
and that work continued as the pandemic began,
she became our point person who sat at many tables
to make sure that resources reached our schools
to counter the impacts of COVID-19.
She's an incredible leader, deeply committed,
incredible parent of a California students,
and we are grateful to have had her service here.
And we wanted to take this moment
to acknowledge you, Lisa Constancio,
formally for your service
at the California Department of Education,
and congratulate you as you begin to continue your service
at the State Board of Education.
Please join me in congratulating and welcoming
and thanking Lisa Constancio.
Thank you.
We do have some certificates here for you, Lisa.
She's declined my invitation for remarks,
but we would be remiss if we didn't have the opportunity
to acknowledge her.
Madam President and members of the board,
thank you for the latitude to be able to acknowledge
Lisa Constancio here today.
This concludes my report.
Thank you so much.
And we're thrilled to recognize Lisa as well
as all in the family,
and we appreciate the fact that she will be continuing
to serve the state from the other side of the building.
So thank you so much.
I am going to reinforce a couple of the remarks
that our state superintendent has made.
And as he depicted, we're really engaged right now
in a process of developing
a whole child approach to education,
which includes the ways in which we think
about all of the supports that children need to be ready
to learn effectively, a whole school approach to that,
and a whole community approach.
So it is a very important moment in the way
in which California is thinking about education policy.
I do want to note also that next week
will mark the two-year anniversary
since the start of the pandemic in California
when we all went home and started trying to figure out
how to do distance learning.
I want to thank all of the educators and families
who have persevered through the most trying conditions
our schools have ever faced to keep students safe
and learning over these last 24 months.
I want to note that compared to other big states
like Florida, New York, and Texas,
California has had the lowest pediatric hospitalizations,
the lowest death rates,
the fewest school closures due to outbreaks,
and that is due to the hard work of our school communities
to provide our students with safe learning environments
and all of the mitigation strategies that the state,
the counties, the districts, the schools together
have put in place to allow for that kind of safety.
Looking ahead, the hospitalization rates
are projected to decline even further,
but as State Superintendent Thurman noted,
there are communities where that is not the case,
where there are actually some increases in case rates
and there are places where we still have to be very,
very vigilant.
So with new surges or variants still possible,
even though the trend is downward,
we have moved into this new phase,
which is anchored in continued vigilance
and reduced disparities in case rates.
Masking schools as the State Superintendent said
will be moved from a required state mandate
to a strongly recommended for local communities.
It is strongly recommended because it is one of the best ways
to protect the health and wellbeing of all of us,
including, of course, the most vulnerable among us,
children who are not eligible for a vaccine,
disabled people, the elderly people
with compromised immune systems,
multiple chronic conditions, and in communities
where case rates have not yet really begun to decline
or hospitalization rates.
So as local decisions are made
regarding whether to maintain or establish
universal masking requirements,
and families are making decisions
based on their own situations,
it will be important for our educators
to reinforce the students and with parents
and with all of the members of the school community
the importance of respecting each other's decisions.
And teachers can model respect
and schools can make sure that the climate
and the culture of the campus is one that puts tolerance,
support, and consideration at the center of our policies.
And of course, the best way to prevent serious illness
from COVID is through vaccination.
We have extraordinary evidence of that
in the differentials that occur for hospitalization
or death rates with respect to the differences
in vaccination rates.
And vaccines have saved lives
and reduced those hospitalizations.
The state continues to offer
mobile vaccine clinics to schools
interested in improving vaccine rates.
We really do need to be paying attention to this right now
and any school that wants to do so
can sign up at toolkit.covid19.ca.gov,
mobile vaccinations.
So we wanna continue to encourage
an attitude and a support system for safety in our schools.
With the end of the school and summer break fast approaching
our schools are gearing up to extend programming
to students into the summer.
And as the governor noted
in his state of the state address yesterday,
expanding access to high quality teaching and learning
is key to moving past COVID
and into a future where all students thrive.
Fortunately, California has been a leader in the US
for access to before, after and summer school programming.
In fact, the Afterschool Alliance ranks California second
after only Washington DC
for access and quality of afterschool programming.
And we have been expanding,
we'll continue to expand the resources and funding
for that programming and for summer school program.
So with $1.8 billion in state investments
in the expanded learning opportunities program
and a total of $5 billion over the next couple of years,
we will soon claim that top spot.
And I hope we will use that time and that opportunity
to really provide both the kinds of academic supports,
everything from high intensity tutoring
and other kinds of academic opportunities
for dealing with the learning recovery process that we're in
and also enrichment in music and the arts and recreation
and all the other things that make a summer of joy
possible for our students and a summer of learning.
Universal TK is also this year beginning its stage
of bringing the next one fourth of the students
into the process of being eligible for TK.
And I will say the Department of Education
is doing yeoman's work to figure out
how to give the technical assistance to districts
to do this opening up and working
with the teacher credentialing commission
to create pathways for staff,
both from early childhood and multiple subjects pathways
and new entrance to the field.
As State Superintendent Thurmond said,
we have a variety of supports,
which are open to TK, prospective TK teachers,
as well as K-12 teachers
in terms of golden state scholarships,
which are available to help students offset
their college costs by $25,000,
the residency programs that are starting up,
including for TK teachers,
the classified staff pathways
that enable paraprofessionals to get a pathway,
a paid pathway into a teaching career.
So we're enthusiastic about and laying the table
for a real growth in our teaching workforce
that allows people to come into teaching in California
without debt, with a high quality preparation
and with a long-term possibility of committing to the field
because it becomes affordable in those ways.
I also wanna just note that as we look at the opportunities
for both TK and for expanded learning
and before and after school time,
we are launching, as the State Superintendent noted,
our community school strategy,
which will allow many schools
to tie all of these efforts together
and to make it possible in a very orchestrated way
to serve the needs of students in their communities.
We will have the possibility over the next couple of weeks
for up to a couple of thousand schools in the state
to get planning grants, implementation grants,
and we will have a technical assistance center
that is responding, is able to be conceptualized
in response to the RFA that's going on.
So we really wanna appreciate the engagement
of the many critical interest holders in this process.
We look forward to continued engagement,
including by our new board members.
We have a lot of work to do
because once we have these resources in place,
implementation is the most important element,
as they used to say in the work I did in policy analysis,
that implementation is the great slip
between the cup and the lip
if you don't pay attention to it.
And we are going to be paying a lot of attention
to being sure that the pathway to doing this work
effectively in our local schools
is made smoother by the work that we do.
And with that, we will dive into our work,
which will get us going on a number of these topics.
We're gonna start with item four,
which is the update on the implementation
of the integrated local, state, and federal accountability
and continuous improvement system.
And the CDE is recommending that we take action
related to the accountability work plan
as deemed necessary and appropriate,
and that we delegate authority to CDE
subject to the approval
of the State Board Executive Director
to pursue as expeditiously as possible a waiver
to allow California to maintain
its DOS modified methods business rules
for calculating academic achievement
and graduation indicators for our alternative schools,
and that we approve the submission
of the 2021-22 addendum for the consolidated state plan
due to COVID-19.
This item will be presented by Cindy Kazanis
and Joseph Saenz of the CDE.
And Cindy and Joe, please begin.
Thank you, President Darlene Hammond, Cindy Kazanis
of the Analysis, Measurement,
and Accountability Reporting Division.
I wanted to welcome the new members today
and also acknowledge that we have some new liaisons
that are helping us with accountability these days,
President Lyndon Darlene Hammond
and Vice President Glover Woods.
We're very excited to bring to you our annual item,
our update on the implementation
of the accountability system.
Some of the work that I do
is to obviously lead the accountability system work,
but also in regards to data reporting.
So data that comes out of the department
typically comes from my office.
I have been in this role since 2015
and have been at the department for 19 years.
So it's really excited to see
some fresh faces here this morning.
So we're gonna cover a couple of topics
to bring you up to speed
on what we've been working on for the past year,
and then also take you into the year of work for 2022,
as well as a couple of years beyond.
I'm gonna be joined by my colleague Joe Saenz
to discuss our proposed waiver
for our Dashboard Alternative School Status Program,
as well as our addendum
that is being offered by the US Department of Education
that we'd like to take advantage of.
So the recommendation, you can see on the screen,
I'll read it once and then we'll have it at the end
just so you're aware of the action.
I know that President Darlene Hammond
gave you a brief overview.
The department is recommending
that the State Board take action related
to the 2022 Accountability Work Plan
as deemed necessary and appropriate,
and that the State Board of Education
delegate to the Executive Director
to pursue as expeditiously as possible
a waiver to allow California
to maintain the Dashboard Alternative School Status
modified methods, business rules for calculating
the academic achievement and graduation rate indicators,
and that the SBE approved California submission
of the 2021-2022 Addendum Template
for the Consolidated State Plan due to COVID-19.
So the past year, just like in schools,
we are seeing a lot of noise in the data
and we'd like to take you through just a couple of things
that we've been working on up to the release
of our major data sets in January of 2022.
So specifically what affected our work
was that we, of course, have still been
part of the pandemic and we've had a lot of disruptions
in schools, and we've had a lot of disruptions
in schools.
This past year, the State Board of Education
applied for a waiver to suspend accountability requirements
for the 2020-2021 school year,
and what this impact meant to the Dashboard
is we did not publish state-level indicators
for each of the metrics.
You will see local indicators, though, on the Dashboard.
Following the action by the U.S. Department of Education
and the approval of that waiver,
we also had relief from state requirements
around accountability as identified under AB 130,
which was passed in July of 2021,
and that mirrored the actions
by the U.S. Department of Education
in that we suspended, the state suspended
the reporting of state indicators
and reporting available data
that would have been included on the Dashboard
were asked to be put on our website,
only if they were determined to be valid and reliable.
And then, as I mentioned, we were able to report out
on local indicator data.
So what that meant in absence of having values placed on it,
performance levels placed on our data,
is that we simply reported out on raw data
around graduation rates, our chronic absenteeism,
as well as many other metrics.
So we did release a version of the Dashboard for 2021
on January 7th, 2022.
You will see district enrollment information,
demographic information, as well as the local indicators.
First, the local indicators
were only for informational purposes,
so you don't see a performance standard attached to it.
In prior years, you would have seen met or not met,
or not met for two or more years.
We also provided the public transparency
into the data around our graduation rates
and our college career indicator.
So the department has been supplementing
what is posted to the California School Dashboard
through a sister website that we host
called the School Dashboard Additional Reports
and Data webpage.
And on that report webpage, you can get information
about a school's four and five-year graduation rates
as we calculate it to align with the accountability standards,
as well as our graduation rate for alternative schools,
which is a one-year graduation rate.
Additionally, you see metrics
around our college career indicator.
So while we're not able to report out on students
who took the grade 11 assessments,
we are able to report out on students who, for example,
completed A through G,
and had completed their career technical education pathways,
or took an advanced placement exam
and passed it with a certain level.
And so that additional transparency is available, again,
through the dashboard and on the department's webpage
when you go to our accountability homepage.
So DataQuest, as many of you probably know,
I've already heard some data reported this morning,
our 6.2 million kids.
That's something that my division calculates
and posts on an annual basis.
DataQuest is really the heart of our data reporting
for the department around educational data.
And so DataQuest continues to report out on, thank you,
on graduation and dropout rates, discipline, absenteeism.
We have a new report called Stability and Stability Rate,
as well as our cumulative enrollment.
That information, again,
was published along with the dashboard in January.
And you can see comparisons between schools, districts,
county, and the state.
Additionally, there are comparisons
for certain reports on grade spans,
on whether or not they're alternative school or not,
whether or not you wanna look at it
by a particular student group,
so English learners, students with disabilities.
There's a lot of accessibility
that is attached to these reports.
And so in absence of having state indicators
on the dashboard, DataQuest has been something
that we've been able to maintain
throughout the COVID-19 and the pandemic phase.
All right, so we're gonna move on to attachment one.
I should have warned you, this is a long item.
And so we will take a break for clarifying questions
after each of the attachments.
And I'll turn it over to President Darling-Hammond
when we take that break to allow for those questions.
So attachment one is our work plan for the year,
and I will get started.
So we are required not only by state but federal law
to restart accountability.
And what does that mean in terms of knowing
that we still have disruptions this school year
in our schools?
Students have been sick due to COVID and had to stay home,
and there's been a lot of concern and consternation
in the field around not only chronic absenteeism rates,
potentially, and their effect on a school
or district determination,
but as well as our upcoming state assessments.
So while we are hearing all of this consternation
from the field, we do have an obligation
because we do take federal and state money.
We have to hold our districts and our schools accountable
through the means that we've put forward on the dashboard
and through our SSA state plan.
So in terms of restarting accountability,
we need to, under the US Department of Education's
requirement, we need to make sure that we are identifying
for the first time in two years schools
for comprehensive support and improvement
and additional targeted support and improvement
using this current school year's data.
Additionally, under state law,
I already mentioned Assembly Bill 130.
We are really, you know, we have guidance from,
or rather, required under this provision
to only use performance data for this current year.
So we will not be looking back at old data
or even last year's data to do comparisons
and to create what we call a performance color.
So the department is restricted from using that prior data,
and so we only are able to display what we call status
or current year data on the California school dashboard.
We are recommending, and you'll hear this later on
through the addendum, that the college career indicator
not be reported because of last year's
2021 statewide assessments
and the lack of statewide participation in the CASP test.
Since that is one of the major pieces
about how students demonstrate
that they're college or career ready,
it's really important that we have a full set of data
in order to calculate that indicator.
So just, again, just to reiterate,
the 2020 tools dashboard will not be able to report change
or the difference from prior year,
and we will not be performing,
reporting out on performance colors
due to these restrictions from assembly bill 130.
So what does this mean?
We are exploring options on a display.
The display you see on this screen
is for the English learner progress indicator
from the 2019 dashboard.
And when the department published this information,
it was to respond to a condition
from the U.S. Department of Education.
But it was also to provide transparency to the field.
In absence of a third year of data,
we were trying to just at least establish a baseline
as to where schools were on this measure.
So we have a foundation about how we've done this before,
but we know that it will be more than
just the English learner progress indicator
that will be showing status only through the entire dashboard.
So in thinking about how we would display
this moving forward, we're asking our contractor,
San Joaquin County Office of Education,
for some mock-ups on making sure that
this is meaningful to schools and to districts
and that they can make decisions
and also talk to the public about what this means
in terms of how their schools and districts are doing.
So what are the other indicators that will be reported
on the dashboard using status and what data are we using
for each of these indicators?
So to begin with, the academic indicator
will be using the 2022 Smarter Balanced Assessments
and California Alternative Assessments
for English Language Arts, Literacy, and Mathematics.
Our Chronic Absenteeism and our Suspension Rate Indicators
use our, excuse me, our 2021
and 2022 Smart Balance Assessments.
Our English Learner Progress Indicators
use our, excuse me, our 2021, 2022 Enrollment Data.
Our English Learner Progress Indicator will use 2020, 2021,
and 21, 22 English Language Proficiency Assessments
for California or LPAC results.
This is a very different indicator
because we do need two years of data to produce status.
And then finally, our Graduation Rate Indicator
will look at the class of 2020.
So we'll look at our graduating class
to determine this indicator.
We'll also look at students in the class of 2021
who took an additional year to graduate
with a full complement of their coursework.
So our fifth year graduates.
And then we'll look at our
Dashboard Alternative School students
who graduated, of course, in 2022.
There has been a lot of conversation in the field.
I think it started maybe week two of school
about the department taking up
whether or not we want to reset cut scores.
And what this means is whether or not the status levels
that were established by the board
over the course of several meetings,
if not half a dozen meetings for each of these indicators,
whether or not the board would take up resetting those
in light of all of the consternation in the field,
the noise in the field,
the fact that we know that we have greater levels
of students being absent due to the pandemic.
And so we spent the last two months asking this question.
We talked to the technical design group
who advises the CDE on technical matters
around the accountability system.
We spoke with the California Patricia's advisory group
who advises you, the state board,
on matters around Title I.
We also talked to the advisory commission
on special education.
I've talked to several of the committees
from the county schools superintendents association.
And there's not clear guidance in the field
or a clear desire in the field on how to proceed.
But with all of these things in mind,
we know that in our SSA state plan,
that we've said that we would revisit cut scores
after a period of seven years.
And while we're hitting up against seven years,
we know that we also have two years
in which we don't have data.
And so one thing that we would suggest is,
let me actually just go over the feedback that we received.
So the technical design group
was not in favor of the adjustments.
They expressed concerns that doing so
may cause the system to lose credibility.
We heard that again
from the California Patricia's advisory group.
And I think this is important to note
that they expressed concerns
that lowering standards may not provide an accurate picture
of what's occurring at schools.
They also had members who expressed
that if cut scores were not reset,
LEAs in schools may not view the dashboard
as a system that reports relevant data.
So again, either ends of the spectrum on this,
we are recommending at this point
that we keep the cut scores as is.
And we continue to monitor it as we collect the data.
And when we look next year to adding in change
or two years of data that we revisit this conversation.
We also saw in some of the letters that you received
from different organizations
and a desire to really focus on how we communicate out
about what this restart around accountability means.
And so we are taking that recommendation
and we will develop a toolkit
for communicating about the 2022 dashboard
when it's released in December.
Right now we have several one page flyers
and the works that are relevant to the status levels,
participation rate, among other things.
And in years past, we've done some webinar slides
that others can use that provide a format for them
to share with members of the public and their community.
And then we have also offered up key talking points.
So we'll work with our educational partners
to put these together as we head up a release
in December of 2022.
So I think with that, we will shift from current year
and we'll shift to things that we're continuing to work on
that is a multi-year process around future dashboards.
So specifically, we're super excited
that we had a little bit of time this last year
to work on developing something
that had been on to do list for several years.
And that was a student level data file
for our college career indicator.
And why this is important is because this kind of data
is not available in a one-stop shop
in our student data system, CalPADs or other places.
And so we developed internally a mechanism
to create an online portal.
We're calling it SOARS,
the Student Online Accountability Record Status.
And what this system allows to do
is to share student level data back with authorized personnel
from local educational agencies and charter schools.
And why this is important and why there's, I think,
been such a thirst from the field to understand this
is the college career indicator brings
just hundreds of thousands, if not millions,
of data points together on each individual student,
looking at their four or five years worth of high school
and giving them credit for what they've accomplished,
things that they've participated in.
It's a very nice compliment for a school
to be able to look at how their students were able
to show that they were prepared
or approaching prepared on this measure.
So we will be releasing this this spring.
And again, it's only available to authorized personnel.
The other thing that we've been working on for several years
and continue to work on,
because you do have to ramp up on these things
around the college career measures,
is the development of two new measures for this indicator
around civic engagement and industry certifications.
And we know that the State Board of Education
has taken action on civic engagement.
And we have been working as a department
to determine how best to collect that information,
whether it's in our student level data system
or in an auxiliary system,
that would capture students' information
as well as how they potentially were able to demonstrate
that they achieved the civic engagement seal.
So we have met with the civic engagement group.
They are very civically active and engaged in a great way,
and in collaboration with our educator excellence division.
And I know that we have a meeting coming up later this summer
in which we'll talk about the data collection plan
for this next couple of years.
Additionally, we have been working
with our college career transition division
under director Pete Callis around industry certifications.
And this is absolutely a multi-year process.
There is not a national standard for any of these metrics.
And so California is really having to take a step back,
look to others, how they've attempted to put it
into something like their accountability system,
how they've attempted to collect this information,
again, through their student level data system.
And so we are continuing that work in 2022 and beyond.
I'm gonna switch over to assessments.
And just so you know, Mal Vang is in the room
in case you have any tough questions
around our assessments.
I know she's up after me for a couple of items.
We are continuing.
The board did take action several years back
that they gave a nod that this California Science Test
or CAST would be included in a future dashboard.
We have been anxiously awaiting for these data to come in,
for us to have two years of consecutive data.
And so I think there's been some consternation in the field.
You saw that in the letters
that we have not been able to act sooner
on including this test into the accountability system.
And because the accountability system
is of course of high stakes,
schools are identified for needs improvement
and eligibility for districts
under differentiated assistance.
It's really important that we get it right.
And so we've taken a tact
in which we've been working very closely
with our assessments division
to make sure that the years of data
that we would use to start this process
are valid and reliable and we can move forward on this.
So there is just a couple of things,
factors that we've been mulling over
and the fact that we've had a limited number of students
completing the assessment during the pandemic is a concern.
The use of the revised blueprint
that the State Board of Education approved back in January
will be in operation this school year.
There is also a need as we think about
bringing it into the dashboard,
not just for informational purposes,
but to actually include in an indicator,
whether it's a standalone indicator
or something that is attached to an academic indicator,
that we need to make sure
that we have the appropriate balance
of academic and non-academic indicators
in our accountability system
under the Every Student Succeeds Act.
So that is another piece of it.
We will continue to update you as we make progress
and as of course we have successful administrations
of this new blueprint in the current school year.
And finally on assessments is our student growth model.
Those of you that were on the board last year,
you had the pleasure of approving
the student growth model at your main meeting.
We are looking forward to a couple of years from now
when we're gonna have the necessary data sets
to actually use the growth model in the accountability system
and use it for actionable decisions at the local level.
So we are going to spend,
as we get our first years of data,
all sets of data in 2022 and 2023,
working with our contractor educational testing services
to make sure that we have the appropriate visual displays
on how to provide this information back to the public
because this is a very complex model
and we need to make sure
that we're communicating appropriately
with not only our educational partners
but with parents and community members
about what this means.
So we are committed to working on that
over the next several years as well.
Shifting gears to teacher data
and teacher data has been a very long process
for us to bring this forward for priority one.
So this year you will see for the first time
the state inputting data into the dashboard for priority one.
Up until now that has been done at the local level
and SB 75, which is passed in 2019,
required the board and the department
to look at what data we collected at the state level
that could replace the local indicators.
So we are currently processing this data set
based on a data sharing agreement
with the commission on teacher credentialing.
And so here's a couple of high level dates
that we think are feasible for us to meet
around getting this data out.
So we are in the process of developing a report
and making sure that the data has met
all of the necessary quality checks
to release on data quest.
That information will be relevant for the reporting
out of this information on priority one
for the 2022 dashboard.
We are also committed this year
to convening an ad hoc policy group
to solicit feedback on how to report this data.
There's been questions around the definition.
We will review the data elements
and also talk about resources to the field
because unfortunately the definitions around teacher data
change depending on what you're reporting on.
So whether it's the dashboard,
the school accountability report card,
the Williams case legislation,
they all have different terminology.
And so we need to make sure
that we are not confusing the field with what we are doing.
We will update the board on our progress this fall
either during an item or through a memo.
And then finally in 2023,
when we have this second year of data
that we're able to release,
we'll come back, circle back to that ad hoc policy group
and engage our technical experts
to develop objective criteria.
We need two years of data to develop objective criteria
based on the standards that we use
for putting items into the California school dashboard.
So my final slide in this section is around next year.
So 2023 dashboard and beyond,
we anticipate again,
that we can restart our performance colors
by adding in a second year of data with change.
And the exception will continue
to be the college career indicator
in which we can only report on status due to again,
not having assessment data from the prior year.
For 2024, we'll bring in all of our indicators
to the dashboard and report out on status,
change and performance colors.
So with that, I'm happy to turn it over
to President Darlene Hammond for any questions,
technical questions from members of the board.
Thank you so much, Cindy,
not only for that really thorough presentation,
but also for all the work you've done for many, many years
to build the new accountability system that we are using,
that really the process started in some sense in 2013
with the local control funding formula.
So we're almost a decade into building this
and your work has been extraordinary in that regard.
Right now, I think we just wanna take
clarification questions and we will go
to discussion questions later for new board members.
I knew a little participant
or there's a little raise hand icon
that will show me if you have a clarifying question
at this time.
And I would like to start off with one if I could
while others are thinking about
whether they have any.
Cindy, could you go back to the slide,
which was the English learner progress slide,
which showed some designations of what was considered,
which numerical rates of progress were considered
to be high, medium, low.
Thank you very much.
And just say a little bit about how those were determined
and is that something that,
I think it'd be good for people to have clarification
on where those come from.
Sure, so this slide, just to again put it into context
is an example of how to report out on status only.
It sounds like your question though is around
how were the scores,
there are the levels that you see on this scorecard set.
So the progress levels that you see,
very high, high, medium, low, very low,
went through a rigorous data analysis process
by my division.
It went through our technical design group
as well as the English learner advisory group.
We have a policy group that advises us on the indicator
who are made up of practitioners as well as researchers.
And with all of those measures or feedback rather
from those groups,
as well as the California Petitions Advisory Group
and the other educational groups
that we always reach out to,
we brought forward a recommendation to the state board
and the state board adopted these,
they're considered cut scores really,
they're based on cut scores.
So this is the status cut scores.
So I think part of what I've heard from other groups
in looking at this, what we call a baseball card,
this may not very, very user friendly.
And we may wanna think about for this one year only
doing something drastically different
than we've ever done around status.
Maybe it's creating a different visual.
We lose some of the text,
but this particular baseball card and the development of it
went through, like I said, a very rigorous vetting process.
The actual display of it had several changes
through especially that policy committee
that advises us on the English Learner Progress Indicator.
And that's how we arrived at this particular one.
The other piece I've heard just as far as feedback
from the field is that unlike our other baseball cards,
this one does not have a comparison to the state.
And so this may not, again,
may not be the best representation,
but this is something that is technically currently
on the website on the 2019 dashboard.
Thank you, that's really helpful.
And I just wanna note that as we were dealing
with all of the challenges last year
of how to get assessments done,
and of course, some districts used
our Smarter Balanced CASP assessments,
others used when they could not administer those,
they used other assessments,
we were able to get a very, very high share
of our English learners assessed on our LPAC assessment.
So the data for this are much more comprehensive
and complete than for the other tests.
And I wanna appreciate all the people
who made that possible both in the department
and in the field for that.
Are there other clarifying questions?
Yes, member Patia Bronson.
Hey, thank you.
I also appreciate the thoroughness of the report
and also that we are creating something new
in the midst of challenging circumstances
with the pandemic and the effect on assessments.
So thank you for your leadership again.
I was just, I wanted to actually ask
for a clarification you had mentioned
in ad hoc policy advisory group.
And if you could just talk about to what extent
community members have been engaged,
parents of EL children,
and also of advocacy organizations
who represent both the children and families.
And just to clarify,
you're discussing specifically
around the English learner progress indicator
or the accountability system?
The LP, yes.
So the English learner progress indicator work group
for accountability that advises the department
has several representatives from LEAs,
including county offices of education
who are very active in the English learner community.
We do have researchers,
including a very notable member from West Ed,
and I'm forgetting Molly's last name,
but just leaders in the field in terms of research.
Magali, I will be able to,
I can give you a list of those names.
They're actually in a board memo from several years back.
So I know that they're in our board item
because we list all of the previous board items
related to our indicators.
So we'll follow up with you,
member Pertio, Bronson.
I guess the related question to that is just,
is there, or can you say more about sort of
what the community engagement plan looks like going forward,
particularly around cut scores in LP?
Sure, I mean, I think that for any of our measures,
what we're hearing from the field is an interest
in looking at cut scores over the next couple of years.
And so I wouldn't treat LP differently
than I would treat any of the other metrics.
That is something that the department worked tirelessly
on to establish.
I am worried.
I know that President Darling-Hammond mentioned
that we've had a great participation rate for our LP
this last cycle.
And so putting together this new set of data
based on post or current pandemic measures,
it'll be, I think overall,
we need to look at what do cut scores look like
moving forward.
But there is not a specific engagement strategy
per indicator.
We do meet with our policy work groups
on a regular basis.
And so we'll go back through that process
and then we'll make sure that
through the California Patricia's Advisory Group,
which members of the public do serve on
and are very vocal about this population of students,
we'll get feedback from them.
And of course, there's obvious opportunities
for public comment during that process.
Right, I'm not seeing any other clarifying questions,
but I do have one.
I believe that you said that in terms of what we'll show
on the dashboard this year,
we will not be using our color coding,
but we'll be giving the status information.
Is that correct?
That is correct.
So it will look different.
We understand that we are very committed to growth
as well as growth and progress,
as well as status,
which will not be possible
for all of the indicators this year.
So it will not look like our normal dashboard,
but it will give information.
Member Lewis.
Just a clarifying question again about status reporting
as it relates to suspension rates.
I think you had a slide that had all of the indicators
on there, but I didn't see one for suspension rates.
So since we didn't have any reporting on the dashboard
for suspension rates since 2019,
and then for this year,
it's gonna be status only, correct?
So does that have,
does that halt disproportionality assignments to districts?
I cannot speak on the disproportionality assignments.
That's our special education division.
I have turned to the slide
in which the indicators are listed,
and we did group suspension with chronic absenteeism.
We have been reporting out on suspension rate on data quest.
So I wanna make sure that I say that out loud.
We know that suspension rates
dramatically decreased last year, the full year of COVID,
and we have heard some consternation
about students returning to the classroom
and some suspension rates going up in certain situations.
Okay, thank you.
You're welcome.
Any other clarifying questions?
I know Cindy has more to tell us.
I don't see any other hands raised,
so I think Cindy, you can proceed apace.
Okay, so this is the quickest attachment,
and I won't pause for questions here
because it's simply telling you,
or rather sharing with you,
the amount of outreach we've been doing over the last year.
And while my entire team of 40 plus staff
have been working remotely, including myself,
we have gotten out to the field.
We have held policy work group meetings.
As you can see, we list the participant numbers,
but I think really the most important one
at the bottom there shows,
we did 26 virtual meetings with over 5,000 participants.
So while accountability is suspended,
there is absolutely still interest
in engaging in how schools are doing,
how districts are doing,
how we can better report on data at the state level
absent accountability or absent a data set.
And so that is really the work that we've been doing
in the division that I'm very proud of,
very proud of the team in light of all those obstacles.
And with that, I'm gonna turn it over to my colleague,
Joe Sines to introduce you to attachment three
and our request for a waiver
from the US Department of Education.
Thank you, Cindy.
Good morning, President Darling-Hammond,
Superintendent Thurman and state board members.
For those of you who don't know me, my name is Joe Sines.
I'm the Federal Policy Liaison
at the CDE's Government Affairs Division.
And I will be reviewing the Dashboard Alternative School
Status or DAS General Waiver.
So just for a review on the origins of the DAS program,
goes back to 2017, California Education Code Section 52052D
allows the establishment of the DAS program.
So this program is intended to ensure
that California's accountability system
fairly evaluates the success or progress
of alternative schools that serve high-risk students.
With the adoption of the Dashboard in 2017,
the SBE acknowledged that the system did not address
the success or progress of students
in alternative school settings.
The SBE subsequently directed the CDE
to develop indicators for alternative schools
that evaluate the success and progress of these schools
based on the LCFF state priorities
and accountability requirements in ESSA.
So the intent was not to develop
a separate accountability system for alternative schools,
but rather to include modified metrics for indicators
on the California School Dashboard Indicators
that fairly evaluate alternative schools.
So as a refresher, schools are automatically assigned
to DAS status because the school type
is identified in education code.
So this would be continuation schools,
county community schools, juvenile court, et cetera,
or is a district-operated special education school
that has at least 70% of students who participate
in the California Alternate Assessment, or CA,
in grades three through eight and grade 11.
We know that the California Alternate Assessment
is given to a very select number of students,
but they are highly concentrated
in district-operated special education schools.
Additionally, we provide an opportunity
for schools to apply for DAS status.
For this, it must be validated
that at least 70% of the school population
is comprised of high-risk student groups.
So this slide gives a representation
of what it looks like in the schools
that are considered DAS due to education code language,
which we see a majority of them are.
Approximately 835 schools, or 80% of those schools,
are automatically assigned by school type.
39 are from the district-operated special education schools,
and 170 schools through the DAS application process.
So looking at it by the numbers,
DAS students represent about 2.5%
of the total number of students in California schools,
151,000 DAS students out of six million total students.
DAS schools represent about 10%
of the total number of schools,
so 1,044 out of about 10,000 total schools.
This is significant for our accountability system.
We have over 1,000 DAS schools,
which far exceeds any other state in the nation.
And the number of students served
in this alternative setting
is also much more than any other state.
So DAS schools receive performance colors
on every state indicator.
However, to fairly hold DAS schools accountable,
we identified three indicators
where we could implement modified methods.
Specifically, these were the graduation rate indicator,
the college career indicator, and the academic indicator.
So just, you know, I know it's hard to even remember 2020,
much less 2017, so for the background,
we can take a look at the timeline of the DAS program.
2017 was when the state board requested
the development of the DAS program,
and the work that went into this program was robust
and done in partnership
with the alternative schools community.
There was a lot of work with CPAC, the state board,
the alternative schools task force,
and other interest groups to develop and vet these proposals.
In 2018, the CDE was able to bring before the state board
to approve the use of modified methods
of state indicators for DAS schools.
In 2020, California received a letter from ED stating
that the use of modified methods
to calculate state indicators for DAS schools
is not permissible.
Specifically, the following is prohibited.
Establishing different cut scores for DAS schools
for the academic indicator,
and using a one-year graduation rate,
which our modified method is.
And so for the continued timeline in 2020,
December of 2020 to be exact,
CPAC received an update on the letter from ED,
and CDE staff received feedback
on the modified measures for DAS schools.
Also, the state board received an information memorandum
on the letter from ED.
Following that, in January 2021,
the SBE approved amendments to California's SSA state plan
to bring the DAS modified methods business rules
for calculating the academic achievement indicator
into compliance with federal law.
Okay.
However, in January 2022, we received two letters from ED
in response to California's SSA state plan amendments.
In February, the SBE received a memo
with a copy of the responses from ED.
All right.
So in the letter from ED, they specifically stated
that CDE's modified methods
do not meet the SSA requirements.
They stated that SSA only allows the use
of alternative accountability metrics for schools
missing the data required for accountability determinations.
In this letter, they specifically called out preschool
through second grade schools.
They did this since C-schools are unable
to have an academic indicator
since they do not test in these grade levels,
and therefore an alternative accountability metric
is permitted.
However, they do not approve this for schools
that do have the necessary data
to receive an accountability determination.
So this would be DAS schools that test students.
Therefore, we cannot substitute an accountability metric.
So this slide takes a look at what the denial
of these amendments have,
the impact of the denial of these amendments have.
We would no longer be able to use
the one-year graduation rate.
We would instead have to use the four-year cohort rate.
Additionally, DAS schools will be held
to the same cut scores for the academic indicator
on the five-by-five performance level grid
as non-DAS schools.
And so this would begin immediately with the 2022 dashboard
that is due to be released this fall.
So there is an option to request a waiver of SSA statute,
which we are discussing today.
This has been done in the past.
This would potentially allow us
to keep the current system in place
and would allow for modified measures for DAS schools
through the DAS one-year graduation rate
under the graduation rate indicator.
Different five-by-five cut scores for DAS schools.
And for the academic indicator,
different five-by-five cut scores for DAS schools as well.
Now we'll walk through additional considerations
that ED provided in the response letter
to the CDE on the DAS amendments.
Specifically, two of the ways they suggested using
to reduce the impact of identification of DAS schools
being over-identified for support
were partial attendance modifications
to dashboard indicators and also to modify
how we assist schools for support.
For partial attendance, we could look at excluding students
who have not attended the same school within an LEA
for at least half of a school year.
For school support eligibility,
we could change the identification pool
for the lowest performing 5% of Title I schools
from all schools to identification school type.
So this would be elementary schools, middle schools,
high schools, and DAS schools.
Additionally, while the CDE is waiting for action
from ED on the waiver,
the CDE is exploring options to continue to include
the modified measures for the graduation rate
on the dashboard for informational purposes.
This may include other yet-to-be-determined measures.
We can also develop a new report that displays
an additional DAS color placement designation
on the school dashboard,
additional reports, five-by-five placement report.
And finally, the CDE is considering the development
of a new report that displays the DAS schools'
distance from standard
without the participation rate penalty.
So we have received,
we currently do have public comment open
for this potential waiver.
It's open through March 30th, 2022.
As of March 8th, 2022, we received 15 comments,
which were all supportive of pursuing the waiver.
Also at the February 2022 meeting
for the California Practitioners Advisory Group, or CPAG,
the members did express support
for pursuing a DAS general waiver.
So now I will pass it back to President Darling-Hammond
and the State Board members.
All right, thank you so much.
Are there any clarifying questions for Joseph?
I am not seeing any yet.
Give it a minute of wait time.
You were exceptionally clear.
So I think we're passing the ball back to Cindy,
is that correct?
No, I'll be handling attachment for as well.
Okay, then carry on.
All right, we are almost to the finish line.
So I think we're going to pass it back to Joseph.
We are almost to the finish line.
Thank you for your attention.
Our next attachment, attachment four,
will be California's 2021-22 Addendum Template
for the Consolidated State Plan due to COVID-19.
So we'll start off for some vital background
on the prior federal COVID-19 waivers.
As you know, the past couple of years,
we have dealt with this in each year.
So I think it's important to have a little bit of background
for our new members and draw a line
of how we got to where we are today.
The first assessment and accountability waiver
we will look at will be the 2019-20 waiver
California submitted.
Due to the extraordinary circumstances created
by the COVID-19 pandemic and resulting school closures,
U.S. Department of Education invited states
to request a waiver for the 2019-20 school year
of the assessment requirements.
Through this waiver,
the states would not need to administer
statewide assessments to all students
to make annual accountability determinations
to identify schools for support and improvement
or to provide data on its state and local report cards
for assessment and accountability information.
Our waiver was supported or submitted
by State Superintendent of Public Instruction,
Tony Thurman, and California State Board of Education
President Linda Darling-Hammond on March 26th, 2020.
And was approved quickly by ED on March 27th, 2020.
For reference, this slide also lists the ESSA sections
that were requested to be waived and subsequently approved.
Now that brings us to the next assessment
and accountability waiver.
For the 2021 school year,
ED offered the COVID-19 state plan addendum
to allow states to modify their accountability systems
described in their state plans
to account for the lack of data
due to the assessment and accountability waivers
from the 2019-20 school year.
This waiver was brought before the SBE
and approved for submission to ED,
requesting that the following requirements be waived.
This was the removal of the 95% participation rate penalty
for the academic indicator,
removal of the requirement to identify schools for support
based on 2020-21 data,
requirement for schools that are currently identified
to support to continue to receive support
in the 21-22 school year.
This allowed states to exit comprehensive support
and improvement or CSI schools
based on the graduation rate if exit criteria are met.
And this requires states resume identification of schools
based on the 21-22 data.
So now we get to the current 21-22 addendum template.
In December of 2021, the ED released
the 2021-22 addendum template
for the consolidated state plan due to COVID-19
to provide states a streamlined process
to modify state plans for only the 2021-22 school year
as they implement accountability
and school identification requirements.
Now it is important to note that any changes
that would go beyond the 2021-22 school year
would require the CDE to use
the regular state plan amendment process,
and this is a very important step
in the amendment process,
and this is noted in the template as well.
So the CDE proposes amending the state plan
by shifting forward timelines two years
for measurements of interim progress and long-term goals,
modifying the school quality indicator,
and for schools eligible for assistance,
this would be change in identification frequency,
change in methodology,
and revising the entrance and exit criteria.
And now I have the pleasure
of passing the presentation back to Cindy.
Thanks, Joe.
So just to note, I know that Joe mentioned
that this addendum is only for the current school year,
and just I think for our new members,
and maybe for some of our older members,
these addendums are unprecedented.
Doing a streamlined waiver and getting a response back
from the U.S. Department of Education in 24 hours
or a week is simply, that doesn't happen,
and I do have to acknowledge
that they have been extremely responsive
to the COVID-19 situation
by preparing things like an addendum template.
This is the third year in a row that they've done it,
and it has really relieved the departments,
state departments of education
from having these onerous requirements
placed on schools and districts,
and we know that there should be other places.
So the Department of Education is recommending,
and we did receive feedback even later on
from the California Fishers Advisory Group
that we take advantage of the opportunity
to shift forward our long-term goals by two years.
This is in keeping with the fact
that we've actually lost two years
in our accountability system
to demonstrate that we are meeting long-term goals
or on our way to the measurements of interim progress,
which are reported out through the dashboard
and on our statement earlier with the cards.
And so we need to make sure
that we're tweeting every indicator the same,
and so you do see our recommendation
that we shift the two-year,
or rather shift these timelines two years
for the academic achievement graduation rate
and the progress in achieving English language proficiency.
So the second piece that we want to also recommend
to the board to take advantage of
is the modification of the school quality indicator.
And in California, we use two indicators to measure this,
suspension rate and college per indicator.
As we were thinking about this particular indicator
and what is a challenge for us,
you've already heard,
on reporting out on the college per indicator data,
we did reach out to the US Department of Education
and had a phone call with them to talk through
if we were not able to report out on this,
would they be amenable to including this in our addendum?
And because we use two indicators to measure school quality,
they said, absolutely,
this is something that the addendum was designed for.
So we are, again, recommending removal of reporting
out on the college per indicator for the 2022 dashboard
due to limitations of that grade 11 assessment
from this past administration, from the 2021 administration.
We will, of course, as you heard earlier,
continue to use suspension rate and report out on that
for all grade levels to meet the requirements
in the Elementary and Secondary Education Act.
The third piece is probably the one
that is one of the more difficult ones.
We are required to identify schools
for the first time in two years.
I've just mentioned that in the prior attachment.
So the identification process
falls into two different categories,
comprehensive support and improvement,
and additional targeted support and improvement.
And these determinations will be made
based on using data from the 2022 dashboard.
As you heard in the previous attachment,
we are prohibited from reporting out
on additional years of data on the dashboard
due to the constraints from Assembly Bill 130.
And so this one-time change in the addendum,
we are gonna be suggesting over the next couple of slides,
several one-time changes that would affect
for the 2022 identification cycle.
So the first piece is the change in methodology.
We have our current state plan
that is approved by the US Department of Education shows,
rather, let me take a step back.
We are going back to using our English Learner Progress
Indicator as an example of how we'd like to change
the methodology by using status only
for identification purposes.
We were in this situation back in 2019
because there was a condition placed on us
by the US Department of Education
to utilize the LP to identify schools.
And so we used a proxy of very low
for our red performance categories.
We did that based on data analysis and simulations,
trying to see, trying to make sure
there wasn't a lot of noise in the data
and that we were identifying the right types of schools,
again, based on this proxy.
We found in that simulation process back in 2018-19
if we used other status levels, for example,
low as a proxy for orange, that we introduced error
or the correlation didn't tend to be as strong.
In November of 2019, the State Board approved
the recommendation to use this in the methodology
and we were able to identify schools
using the English Learner Progress Indicator
as part of the methodology.
So we are suggesting that we take the lessons learned
from this one indicator
and apply it to the entire dashboard.
We have done additional simulations
now that when the addendum came out,
we met internally, we thought about how we could
bring forward this item to you
and make sure that it was based on a recommendation
that was valid and reliable and technically sound.
And so these simulations have been run
by our technical design group
as well as the various policy groups
that I've mentioned previously.
What we found is very low is,
I know we use the word decent,
but it is an appropriate proxy for red.
We did confirm with this new simulations that we conducted
that low, medium, and high,
and so the corresponding colors would be orange,
yellow, and green are not suitable proxies for the color
because of the increased level of error.
And you can see that in the data
that I show below on this slide.
So you can see at either ends of the spectrum,
very low and red and very high and blue,
there's a high correlation,
but as soon as you get into orange and yellow and green,
there's just a much higher level of error
that is introduced because you're bringing change
into the situation, it has more of an impact.
So in thinking about how to shift eligibility criteria,
again, for this one year only,
we went back and we looked at
what our current eligibility criteria was
in our SSA state plan.
That is what you see on the screen,
but we've made some edits to it.
So the suggestion that we started with was,
let's simply cross out anywhere that it said a color
and substitute it for the corresponding status level.
We know that each of these criteria,
I should say that you saw that they all introduce error,
some of them higher than others
because status is not in a direct correlation
or proxy for color.
And in looking at this list,
I should actually just take a step back.
When we look at schools for comprehensive support
and improvement, the first category we need to look for
is any school that has a graduation rate less than 68%.
We take those out of the pool, they're identified.
We then look at Title I schools.
So Title I schools who meet the criteria below,
and this is done in the hierarchical method.
So the requirement for the low performing
comprehensive support and improvement identification
is that we identify 5%, not rounding up to 5%,
but at least 5% of schools in the state.
And so the simulation results that you see below
on this slide, we use the status criteria
from the 2019 dashboard.
We applied this methodology,
so using a proxy of very low for red.
And the descriptions that you see,
so this is referring to each of the indicators.
So if I'm a school with, a high school rather,
you may not have as many indicators
as an elementary school may.
And so that's why these categories are all very low,
all very low except one majority and very low.
So that's each of the indicators together
create these descriptions.
So to walk you through what this slide is trying to tell us
is that for all very low,
if we were to use the 2019 data,
we would see 163 schools being eligible,
Title I schools being eligible for assistance.
That equals 2.4% of our Title I schools,
again, minus those that had already been identified
for graduation rate, low graduation rate.
We bring in the second criteria, we go,
if this is moving cumulative, we get up to 4.9%.
Keep in mind, we have to get over 5%.
So we need to bring in at least that third criteria,
we'd come up to 7%.
If we brought in the fourth criteria, we'd be up to 11%.
So well above and beyond the requirements
of the Every Student Succeeds Act for California.
So with that in mind,
the two status criteria of all very low
and all very low except for one gets us to 4.9%.
And my staff tell me that's eight schools short of 5%.
We know that life has changed dramatically
in our schools since 2019.
And there is a high likelihood that we will be able
to only have to use those first two criteria
to meet the 5% threshold.
But just in case we don't,
we wanna make sure that we have a backup plan.
And so this is another look at the data.
This is simply giving you a bit of context
for those of you that I know
President Donny Hammond likes to look at data,
look at the error that is introduced.
So we looked at the 2019 data.
And if we are using the status levels instead of color,
we're actually identifying 64 more schools
using this methodology 135
using the first two methodologies and so on.
And so just another look at the fact
that it's not a perfect correlation of proxy
between red and very low.
So the recommendation is from the department
that we use criteria one and two.
And if we don't meet that 5%, we incorporate criteria three.
So you see those criteria in the addendum,
the first three criteria.
We don't believe we need criteria four
because based on, again, our simulations,
we know we're gonna get to 5%
just with those first three criteria.
And with that, I think turn it back over
to Joe to close this out.
Okay, and just to review our feedback on this
from interest groups, at the February, 2022 CPAC meeting,
the members expressed support for our proposal
to submit the 2021-22 addendum template.
And so finishing off our recommendations,
the California Department of Education
recommends that the State Board of Education
take action related to the 2022
Accountability Work Plan as deemed necessary and appropriate,
that the SBE delegate to the SBE executive director
to pursue as expeditiously as possible
a waiver to allow California to maintain
DAS modified methods business rules
for calculating the academic achievement
and graduation rate indicators,
and that the SBE approve California's submission
of the 2021-22 addendum template
for the consolidated state plan due to COVID-19.
Simple enough.
How simple on a scale of one to 10.
So before we get into public comment or discussion,
I wanna just be sure that if there are clarifying questions
on the last portion of the presentation, we take those.
And it is complicated.
I do have one clarification.
It's complicated.
I do have one clarifying question myself
that I'd like to ask and if others do,
and then we will go into fuller discussion of everything.
So Cindy, you did a good job of explaining to us
how we need to recreate five percentage of Title I schools
need to be identified for support and intervention.
And of course, we've always done that in the past
with growth and progress and status being considered.
Obviously, this is not the approach we would have chosen.
It's the approach that meets the federal requirement
for this year.
You start off mentioning the high schools
who have less than a 68% graduation rate.
When you identify those, do they count into the 5%?
And maybe you could help us understand the relationship
between the two sets of calculations,
the high school calculation, and then of course,
you know, the identification of other schools
who are rated very low on the status indicator.
Absolutely, and in fact, I wish I had a graphic
because I do think this is not intuitive.
There's a Venn diagram in there somewhere, I think.
This is not intuitive.
So the first step when you look at identification
for comprehensive support and improvement
is to look at all high schools in the state
and see if they fall below that 68%.
If they do, they're automatically in
and they're taken out of the pool of schools.
We then shrink the pool of schools to just Title I schools,
which was, I just wanna go back to my numbers,
which is 6,852 for 2019.
So that N at the top of this last column here.
So the 5% is based on schools that are in the pool
after we've removed the low graduation rate
that are Title I.
So we need to do 5% of 6,852,
and that calculation is 343 schools.
You can see on the second full bullet on this slide.
That was, again, for 2009.
Yeah, so the high schools that are identified
are in addition to, I mean, they're sitting over there
as a separate group.
Correct, they're sort of skimmed off the top.
That's how I would put it.
You skim them off the top,
and then you have a shrunken pool
that you start with for the 5%.
Gotcha, and those high schools come from
not only Title I high schools,
but any high schools in the state?
Correct, any high school in the state
that has a graduation rate lower than 68%,
regardless of funding status, would be identified.
So I just wanted to be sure everybody
kind of understood what we're going for.
And if I understood you correctly,
you think that probably when we do the,
this is based on simulations,
but when we do the analysis,
it may very well be that we only use
criteria one and two.
Yes, I mean, I can't predict the data.
I gave up on that after we had the first year of COVID,
but it does seem like because we were so close in 2019,
that we will probably get to that
with the first two criteria.
And then my last question, which could lead us,
I don't wanna go too far into discussion
because we wanna get public comment,
but if we did have to go to criteria three,
are we anticipating any way of
slicing that so that we don't have to add another,
whatever, 200, 300 schools, 400 schools to the mix?
Yes, so I've changed the slide.
So I've gone back to that simulation that we did.
And we did add in what, roughly 150 more schools
with the simulation.
We can't stop at 5%.
We have to apply that metric universally.
That was one of the conditions that we negotiated
with the U.S. Department of Education.
Actually, in person, I was there in Washington, D.C.
several years back.
So it is unfortunate because it does bring us up
well over the 5% based on these simulations.
But you can see there that I think we feel pretty confident
about the criteria one and two
may be the only ones we need to apply
so we can get closer to that 5% of schools.
Okay, thank you.
I don't want to belabor that now.
Are there any other clarification questions?
I am not seeing any hands coming up.
So with that, we want to encourage folks
to queue up for public comment.
We are going to ask our liaisons
for any comment they want to make.
Then we're gonna take a few minutes break
because there's a technology concern
for getting the public comment line open.
So you'll have a moment to get a quick cup of coffee
or whatever, and then we'll come back.
So just to give you a little foreshadowing.
And well, if you are interested
in providing comment on this item,
you can call the telephone number
and use the access code shown on this slide.
And your comments will be limited to one minute.
We want to remind you when you do call in
to turn down the volume of your computer
on the live webcast to avoid background echoes.
And so with that, I'm going to ask our liaison,
Vice President Glover-Woods,
if she'd like to make a comment,
and then I will make one,
and then we will take a little break.
Thank you very much.
Just a couple of very brief comments.
But first, just expression of gratitude
to Cindy, Joe, and the CDE staff for working with this.
Again, not simple at all as we try to ensure
that our accountability system continues to be reflective
of what was needed in the midst of all of the changes
that have happened.
So thank you so very much for all of the work
and the timeless hours that have gone into sharing
what you've shared with us in this item today.
Just a couple of points I'd like to make
before we move forward.
And one is just to underscore how important it is
that we do indeed restart our accountability system
to ensure that all of our LEA schools and students
are receiving the support that they need.
In that same vein, it's also important that our restart
respond to what we know has taken place
in our assessment actions over the last couple of years.
So the communication toolkit
that was referenced a little earlier in the presentation
is going to be very, very key
so that our community understands
how we're reflecting the data as a result
of not using our performance level colors
and really reflecting the status change
in the upcoming dashboard,
as well as providing the support that LEAs will need
to communicate this information
to not only their governing boards,
but their communities and families as well.
So thank you for that and looking forward
to just ongoing work to make sure
that things are crystal clear
and that as we move forward
with representing the status only information
on the dashboard, that it's done in such a way.
Of course, that does not confuse people
with the way we've represented our performance level colors
when we do indeed have data with status and change.
The other couple of points that I wanted to bring forward
is that very excited and encouraged
by the future plans and next steps
that Cindy outlined in the presentation.
I think it will just help for us to enhance the support
that we provide to students
by enhancing the level of data that we will receive.
And just to continue to underscore how important it is
to be in collaboration with our educational partners
in the development of those next steps.
The pursuant of the waiver for the DOS schools
is critical, again, not to rehash,
but we've already heard the support that is there,
knowing that the methodology that was developed
for our DOS schools was done so thoughtfully
to be reflective of what we feel was necessary
in reflecting the data for students in California
that attend those schools.
And so just quite excited that we will continue
to pursue a waiver for that,
as well as the other flexibilities
that will be outlined in our 21-22 addendum.
So again, just in closing of my comments,
President Darley Hammond and members,
fellow members of the Board, a restart is critical,
and it's time for us to continue to move forward
with this robust accountability system
to be sure that our schools receive the supports
that they need.
Also as critical in the restart is how we restart
to be sure that our LEAs have the data necessary
to make the plans that will be so critical
in supporting our students moving forward.
So thank you very much, President Darley Hammond,
for a moment just to speak to this item.
Thank you, and I'll just add on a couple of thoughts.
Again, I wanna underscore how much work is going on
by the members of our leadership
in the State Department of Education
and the previous Board and this Board
in building this accountability system
to really represent more indicators of how kids are doing
and what kinds of support they're getting.
And that is a really important foundation
for what we will want to be doing next.
The momentary need to identify schools
only on the basis of status is,
as you all no doubt know, really at odds
with the philosophy and the approach
that the Board has adopted in California,
which is that school employees are always trying to,
whatever students come to school with,
enable them to make substantial progress.
The recognition of that progress has been
at the core of California's effort, by the way.
We were one of the first states to do that.
Other states have since taken a page from our books,
so we have discussed the fact that the frame in California
now is not one of shame and blame
or pointing fingers at schools
that are serving high-need students
in an era of high need,
that this really is about support and improvement
about getting resources from the SIG grants
to the schools that demonstrate the greatest needs
and to do that in a way that acknowledges
the efforts that educators have been making
all across the state to meet the needs of their students
and to meet the needs of the times.
And I know that my colleagues
in the Department of Education
completely agree with that framing,
and that is how the framing will be communicated
to the field when those identifications are made.
It is important in some respects
to try to get that 5% line
that is required by the federal government
as close as possible to that number
so that we are giving as much support as we can
to schools to make it practicable
for them to do some really thoughtful improvement steps
in the next coming years.
So the final point that Vice President Glover Woods
has made is that this is a moment not only to restart,
but also to rethink.
The Department of Education has issued some guidance,
which invites states to think about
how to configure indicators in their accountability systems
that take account of opportunity to learn
about what kids are experiencing
as well as how they're doing on multiple measures.
We've already gone further down that path
than many other states,
but we will want to take advantage of that invitation
to think together with our leadership in the department
about where does California wanna be in the next decade,
having built on what we started a decade ago.
So with that, I'm told that the folks have called in
for public comment, can stay on the line,
but there is a need for a brief break
because of a technology need to establish
the call in line in the right way.
And now I have said everything that I understand,
I'm at the edge of my technological competence.
So we're gonna take a break for about five minutes.
It is 1109, let's try to be back at 11, let's say 15.
We'll give ourselves six minutes
for that technology need to be met.
And we'll see you then, do not leave the meeting,
just turn off your video and your microphone.
Thank you.
All right.
We are now looking for public comments.
I understand there are callers in the queue.
Linda, just before we do that,
would you like me to reestablish our quorum?
Yes, please do that.
Sorry, I know we're a little bit out of order today
with our technologies.
Yeah.
Member Rodriguez.
Present.
Member Patillo-Brownson.
Here.
Member McQuillan.
Member Orozco-Gonzalez.
Present.
Member Olken.
Member Lewis.
Present.
Vice President Glover-Woods.
Here.
Member Escobedo.
President Darling-Hammond.
Here.
Member Bonacca.
Member Quorum.
All right, we're ready for public comment.
Please state your name and affiliation for the record.
Remember to turn down the speaker volume of your computer
if you're following the live feed.
Speakers are limited to one minute each.
Okay, it looks like we have 12 people signed up
in the queue for public comment.
Again, this is for public comment for item number four.
I will open the phone line down.
Good morning, State Board of Education.
Please state your name and affiliation for the record.
You have one minute.
Your time starts now.
Hello, this is Shilpa Ram from Public Advocates.
We have two requests of the state board relative
to the Priority 1 teacher quality indicator.
First public advocates ask that the state board direct
CBE to include a more robust Priority 1 indicator
in the dashboard work plan.
To align with Ed Code that more robust indicator needs
to be based on teachers who are both fully credentialed
and properly assigned and not only on the relatively
few teachers who are misassigned as Item 7 had proposed.
The agenda item in today's presentation did not
include the need to make the Priority 1
indicator more robust and it's important that that happens.
Second we appreciate the proposal in today's
presentation to include educational partners
in the work to establish objective criteria
for Priority 1 and conclude the work next year.
Thank you for ensuring that the dashboard work plan
include a stronger commitment to full
implementation of Priority 1.
Thank you.
Good morning State Board of Education.
Please state your name and affiliation for the record.
Your time starts now.
This is Suzanne Cooey of the Charter School
Development Center.
Good morning board members.
CSCC strongly encourages the state board
to aggressively pursue the preservation
of modified metrics for DAS schools to fairly
and appropriately evaluate a DAS school's impact
on their students as Attachment 3 states.
Fair and appropriate evaluation of schools impact
on students should be a primary focus of our data
and accountability system.
But we have multiple issues at the school level.
In addition to DAS methods the federal department
rejected the CDE's formulas for the English
Learner Progress Indicator and the CDE's
participation rate penalty.
The CDE version more accurately reflected
student performance.
The new federal participation rate penalty
will tank the academic indicators for example
when small student groups are affected.
The state does not have to use the federal
version for the state's purposes including charter.
Will time is up.
In fall 2023 it will be more than shame and blame.
It will mean school closure based on imperfect data.
So I hope we can address that. Thanks so much.
Thank you so much.
Good morning State Board of Education.
Please state your name and affiliation for the record.
Your time starts now.
Hi my name is Shay Fairchild and I've been
a teacher for the past 16 years with my current
assignment as a teacher on special assignments
to implement and train TK-12 teachers in science.
Additionally I just completed my four year
term as a member of the Instructional Quality
Commission an experience that has profoundly
changed my educational career.
Through that experience I have learned that we are partners.
CDE State Board of Ed and districts.
And without your support we cannot do our job
with full fidelity. Let me explain the issue.
In my district I have been given 30 minutes
with elementary school teachers and approximately
11 release days for secondary teachers
in the past four years pre-pandemic.
For the implementation and the instructional
shifts required for the change in NDSS
and for many districts we are further ahead.
This is where you guys come in and the voice
for equity and access.
Our students in the state of California.
Thank you Coller your time is up.
Thank you Coller.
Good morning State Board of Education.
Please state your name and affiliation for the record.
Your time starts now.
Good morning Dr.
Darla Hammond and board members.
Diana Vu on behalf of the Association
of California School Administrators.
Access concern that a dashboard that's
limited to only status will display an incomplete
picture of the performance of LEAs in each indicator.
Commit to the lack of change in performance
level colors.
Acts request the following.
One annotation on this 2022 dashboard
acknowledges that COVID-19 pandemic abruptly
disrupted education.
The narrative should also include should also explain
why the dashboard is only displaying STAB support.
Two the CDE's communication plan and toolkit for LEAs
include helping explain the anomalies captured
within the 2022 dashboard to parents and the community.
Three a narrative text box accompanying each state
indicator that enables LEAs to narrate their unique
challenges and gain gains during this unprecedented time.
Lastly access strongly supports a waiver request
to the U.S. upon education to continue the use
of alternative metrics within our state county
systems for DAS schools. Thank you.
Thank you.
Next caller please state your name and affiliation
for the record. You have one minute.
Your time starts now.
Good morning. This is Katina Salazar
with California's Together.
We would like to highlight the need to revisit
the definition of English learners for the academic
indicators by defining the EL subgroup as current EL
only to make visible the need to address
students in their classrooms now and in the LCAP.
Using the data files to file a department
with the current status criteria only 98 schools
would be identified by the EL subgroup.
This is less than 10 percent of all the schools
in California with 30 or more English learners.
Although not part of the federal addendum only 2 to 6
would be identified by the differentiated assistance
for the English learner subgroup.
This is not a new issue as we have thought this up
in the past few years but would really
appreciate your consideration. Thank you.
Thank you.
Next caller please state your name and affiliation
for the record. Your time starts now.
Good morning and welcome new board members.
My name is Jessica Sacco.
I'm calling in on behalf of Children Now.
Since districts focus on dashboard indicators
we encourage that the board start to add science
to the dashboard starting with reporting performance
in 2023 and then adopt a 5 by 5 color matrix
in 2024.
Furthermore we encourage the board to start now
to model ways to incorporate the growth model
into the dashboard because we believe it is the single
best measure of school quality.
We support seeking the federal waiver
for alternative schools and think that additional
work is needed to strengthen accountability
for these schools.
For the 2022 dashboard please allow easy access
to the full scope of teacher data available
including teacher assignment ineffective
and out of field teachers broken down by student group.
And finally specifics are included in the LCFF
equity coalition and Alliance for Student Success
letters on all of these topics and more.
Thank you. Thank you.
Next caller please state your name
and affiliation for the record. Your time starts now.
Good morning Dr.
Darling-Hammond and members.
This is Derek Lennox on behalf of the California County
Superintendents Educational Services Association.
We support the CDE's proposal to pursue a waiver
to allow California to maintain dashboard
alternative school status modified methods business
rules as DAS school serves some of California's
most vulnerable and transient students.
We are concerned that the changes to the current
modified methods could portray an inaccurate picture
of our DAS school students outcomes as well as result
in an over identification of DAS schools
for comprehensive support and improvement.
So we applaud and thank the CDE and state board
for your ongoing commitment to equity
and for ensuring that each of our six million
students are fairly represented in our
statewide accountability system. Thank you.
Thank you.
Next next caller please state your name
and affiliation for the record. Your time starts now.
I'm Peter Ahern from the California Association
of Science Educators.
I want to thank President Darling-Hammond
for reiterating the board's commitment to having
science on the dashboard at the last SBE meeting.
We thank CDE for clarifying the conditions
for putting science on the dashboard.
CDE points out that NGSS implementation is stalled
and suggested that this might be a reason to delay
putting science on the dashboard.
In fact it's the other way around.
Districts are told to use the dashboard
to inform their LCAP so when they don't see science
on the dashboard they don't fund NGSS implementation.
Science is likely to be on the dashboard
after testing in 2023 given CDE's timeline.
Districts need to plan for this indicating science
as a status only indicator or creating a placeholder
indicating that science is coming would do a great
deal in signaling districts to fund science implementation.
In addition we also ask the board to please
support Assembly Bill 2565 author Rubio
which would finally help fund long-term teacher
leadership capacity and professional development
for any.
Thank you Coller.
Thank you Coller. Your time is up.
Next Coller please state your name
and affiliation for the record. Your time starts now.
Good evening members of the State Board of Education.
This is Manuel Bonrostro with Californians Together
and we support the recommendations
in the LCFF Equity Coalition Letter.
Specifically for this I am calling to highlight
our concerns with the low expectations
that the current LP Cuts course set for districts.
The current Cuts course would rate districts
as very high even when over one in three
of their English learners do not make progress.
This leaves complaints to see in the system.
Moreover based on the 2019 data only 20 school
districts were identified as very low and rolling
less than 1 percent of all English learners.
In a true equity equity focused system we would want
expectations to be set based on what we want
to see in the system not based on the previously
inequitable outcomes of the past.
This is why we continue to ask the State Board
of Education and the department to revisit
the LP Cuts course and that it be included
in the DemDem template. Thank you.
Thank you.
Next caller please state your name and affiliation
for the record. Your time starts now.
Hi my name is Leticia Garcia on behalf
of the Riverside County Superintendent of Schools.
We support staff's request to pursue a waiver
to maintain the DAS modified metrics for calculating
the academic achievement and graduation rate indicators.
We believe the DAS program is a balance between high
accountability for alternative schools and an opportunity
to be successful.
This modification is critical because our
students come to us at various stages
of their academic career.
We service our students within the framework
of MTSS promoting the whole child approach
which means restorative practices ensuring literacy
financial literacy providing mental health
supports tackling racism and promoting equity.
We do not reduce rigor or lower expectations.
We believe the DAS program is rooted in equity
and provides real accountability and real equity
equitable opportunities for our students.
Thank you.
Next caller please state your name and affiliation
for the record. Your time starts now.
Good morning President Darling-Hammond
and members of the board including the new ones.
Liz Guiana Public Advocates for the LCFF Equity Coalition.
We support the waiver request to the U.S.
Department of Education on how California calculates
academic achievement and graduation rate
indicators for alternative schools.
We appreciate the department's transparency
in sharing their work plan to continuously improve
our multiple measures accountability system
but we would like the work plan to clearly
and publicly include more robust teacher
indicators for priority one.
Not just the teacher missed assignments
but fully credentialed and properly assigned teachers.
Also the state science test should be included
in the next dashboard even if it's just
status only performance.
We know that what gets measured matters.
And since status will be the way for all other
indicators it would not be confusing.
And finally now that we're submitting
an ESSA addendum template we think it's a good
opportunity to refine the definition
of being Gresh learners.
Thank you caller.
Honestly show the school needing support. Thank you.
Thank you.
Next caller please state your name
and affiliation for the record.
Your time starts now.
My name is Kelly Garcia and I am a science
teacher at Hutchinson Middle School
in La Mirada California.
More importantly I'm the grandmother to Hudson
Glenn Olivia and Miles.
All future California public school students.
I'm here today to strongly urge you to place
a place science placeholder on this California
school dashboard.
We learned through the events of the past two
years that having a scientifically literate
population is important for our quality of life.
In addition the fastest growing careers in our
state are strongly connected to science
and technology further emphasizing the necessity
of an effective science education.
When you consider that girls typically make
career decisions by the age of 11 and many
students in our underserved communities often
don't know anyone who works in STEM field it is
all too apparent that we must take steps
to solidify accountability to ensure all
students are equitably prepared for a future
workforce.
As a classroom teacher I'm well aware of the struggles
that teachers schools and districts have had
in implementing NGFS.
Thank you.
Stand long before closing.
Next caller please state your name and affiliation
for the record. Your time starts now.
Good morning.
Colleen Pagter on behalf of the Los Angeles Unified
School District.
Los Angeles Unified is concerned that making no
adjustments to cut points or indicator definitions
will contribute to an over-identification
of schools particularly in terms of ATSI.
The premise of the accountability system
is to target supports at high need schools.
If too many schools are identified it becomes
difficult to do so and the targeted funds that are intended
for interventions and supports would be diluted.
Therefore we recommend that CDE conduct and make
public a comprehensive analysis to determine
the likely number of schools that will be identified
in 2022 especially for ATSI.
Based on the proposed actions in order to reduce
the number of schools for targeted support
we ask that you consider using the available
federal flexibilities by adjusting the definition
of chronic absenteeism for 2022 accountability to acknowledge
the impact of the pandemic and COVID related absences.
Lastly we ask that CDE include 2019 student group
performance as a factor for ATSI designations
since one year status not constitute chronic
underperformance. Thank you.
Thank you.
That concludes public comment for item number four.
All right.
Lots to chew on here and I'm sure people have many,
many thoughts.
I have a few myself but I'm gonna wait until others
have a chance to get their questions on the table.
Yes, member Escobedo.
Yes, I understand the LPAC cut scores.
We had rigorous data analysis by researchers
and people in the field.
However, I do believe there needs to be an increase
of confidence and I just wonder if there's a way
we can triangulate some scores along with these cut off
scores what I mean specifically like perhaps we can look
at the percentage of long-term English learners
and maybe average scale scores and see how they
are connected to those schools that are either very high
or in the middle or very low.
So you would think that you're very high school
according to LPAC you would have less number of long-term
English learners compared to the other levels
as well as probably a higher scale score average.
So I just wonder if we can look at data and associate data
and connect data and maybe more coherence
to create more meaning.
I would love to see that if that's a possibility
in the future of course.
Is that something you wanna ask Cindy to respond to
if it's true?
Please, please.
Hi, this is Cindy Kazanis,
Director of the Analysis Measurement
and Account of the Reporting Division.
So I think the comment that you're bringing up
are mixing data points that I would need to take back
to the team and to our policy advisory group.
It seems to me as well that there's a lot
of misunderstandings about the purpose of the indicator
and what it's designed to do.
And so I would like President Darling-Hammond
if we can also touch base with the accountability liaisons
on next steps so that we can perhaps clear the air
and make sure that the indicator is working
as it was designed.
But also when we think about how we select
or how districts are identified for support,
it's not just based on one indicator
and there is very specific methodology requirements
that are outlined, the Board adopted those criteria.
And so I think there's a lot more at this
as part of this particular issue
than simply doing a simulation of various data points.
Are there other comments or questions?
Well, I have my little, oh, there, Member Rodriguez.
Okay, thank you.
And so we're addressing all of the issues
that were brought up, right, Craig, in our comments?
Yeah, any issues at this point, this is the time to do it.
All right, wonderful.
So with regard to the Doss School Waiver,
I just want to say that I'm in full support of it
because I understand what our students are,
especially our foster students who are in Doss schools,
the support that they need.
And I have a lot of firsthand accounts with those students.
And so I just wouldn't want to make the,
I'm sorry, I'm really sick
and so I'm having a hard time
getting my thoughts together here.
But I'm in favor of the waiver and the calls
and the letters that we received for all of those reasons.
Second, I think that with regard to the cut scores,
we have a great opportunity here.
One of my observations during distance learning
is that my students who really struggled
were those who were extrinsically motivated
or those who depended a lot on direction
and just constant monitoring
as opposed to the internal motivation
that as teachers, we want our students to have.
And so I think to look at the scores,
to look at where we are now
is a snapshot of how we can move forward
and take our students to really focus
on internal motivation and a love of learning
that they can carry on to their future studies.
And in the event that we have to face something
like this again, that our students are prepared,
that they have the skills that they need.
So looking at the snapshot now is the way it is,
I think is really good information
for all of us here in the state.
I'm also concerned about science
because I really, as the caller said,
what's measured is what's valued
and as districts are looking at their planning for funding,
if we don't have any science representation on there,
it'll be hard to make determinations for the future.
Thank you.
Are there other questions or comments?
I'd like to pick up on the last point
that member Rodriguez made and then member Glover-Woods,
I'll come straight to you, I saw your hand go up.
Not electronically, the old fashioned way.
On the question of science, I would like to ask,
I came up from several callers
and it's an interesting point
that we are reporting only status this year.
Is there a reason why we could not report status results
for science in 2022?
Is that your question too, member Glover-Woods?
Member Darling-Hammond, so we will get the first test results
of this data based on the new blueprint this fall
and for us to turn around something of a new test,
I don't think it's feasible,
but I will take it back to the team.
We will have the conversation to make sure
that we can rule out any pieces of it,
but in order to put it out for informational purposes,
because bringing it on for status
and determining that it's an indicator,
you're gonna need to have further discussions
about how you weight those academic indicators.
And so it's not just simply putting information on
and saying there's a status level,
it's also saying how do you value it
in place of all of the other indicators
because it's a very careful balance of academic
versus non-academic indicators
on the dashboard at this point.
Yeah, so that is something that the department
is inviting states to reconsider
because the law does not include some of the constraints
that were in the decision earlier.
But I guess the companion question might be
whether we could display it on the dashboard
for informational purposes without taking into account
its use in accountability,
which we wouldn't want to do
until the following year anyway,
so to use it for informational purposes.
And I'm happy to bring that to you back
as an action item later on this year.
Thank you.
Member Glover-Woods, you are raising your hand.
President and Darlene Hammond,
you asked the question that I was going to ask
and I've received the response, thank you very much.
Thank you.
I have a couple of others,
but I want to just be checking
to make sure nobody else has some questions.
A second point that was made by a caller
that I thought was a useful one,
and you may already have this in mind to do,
but I just wanted to raise it was that the question
came up about in a toolkit for LEAs,
finding a way to help them explain
all of the anomalous results because it is complicated
and we're in our own learning mode
and every school board in the state
will have its own learning mode.
So I just wanted to let you respond to that question.
Yes, absolutely.
So we did include a slide on a communications toolkit.
It was an idea we definitely took from one of the letters
and is something that we have done in years past.
We've worked very closely
with State Board of Education staff, excuse me,
who have just a really keen insight
on talking about these very meaty things
in a very basic manner so that the public can understand
and it's not meant for just a bunch of data
and accountability geeks.
So in that term, we will definitely be spending
the next several months if not
until we release the dashboard,
up until we release the dashboard
on how to help with messaging
and talking about this restarting of accountability
and what it means and how districts and schools
who are identified for support
are actually supported in our system of support,
which is, of course, very unique in California.
And I know that our partners at CCE
and the county offices have been very eager
to get this new set of data
and start working with schools
based on current information.
Yeah, I truly appreciate that.
And I think the way you are stating it
is very important that this really is about
organizing support, so that's terrific.
One other question that came up from a caller was
whether in order to, if we did get to the point
where criteria one and two were not sufficient
to identify 5% of Title I schools,
whether we might not look in a global way,
but for example, use the delete the chronic absenteeism
indicator or otherwise use the flexibilities
that have been indicated that the department
might be willing to have around the selection process
rather than the version that we had approved
over many years ago.
Just wanted your thoughts and comments on that,
on that kind of more refined approach
if we have to go to a third criterion.
Yeah, so I guess, let me tease it out
because I don't see the third criteria
as being connected to the chronic absenteeism statement.
The chronic absenteeism statement
is they want us to reset cut scores
so that it's not over identifying schools.
And if you recall the criteria.
Or not using it in the calculation
was what I thought I was hearing,
but to your point, yes.
Yes, so I mean, at this point, I mean,
that we are recommending that you use all indicators
at the college career indicator.
I do have to point out that one indicator
will not get you identified assuming
that you have sufficient end sizes for the other indicators.
So it would be extremely unusual
that just by having read on chronic absenteeism
that you would be automatically,
and you'd have to have low performance
on your ELA and math assessments.
You'd have to have low performance,
for example, on your English learner progress indicator
status on graduation rate.
And so it's not a one and done.
This is a multi-measures system for a reason.
And in doing that, it's very hard to predict.
I'm not going to predict.
I said that earlier on what these data will look like
come fall of 2022.
We know the field is hurting
especially on chronic absenteeism.
But I would also just mention that if you are identified
as a school for comprehensive support and improvement,
you get money from the state.
The state actually gives you funding
to help support you in this effort.
That is unusual in our system of support
the way it's designed these days.
So just a point of clarification on the eligibility process,
identification, and then I think it's very difficult
for us to do a bunch of what ifs.
But at this point, we are recommending you stick
with the indicators that we've recommended
and with the cut scores as is.
I think the concern will be if we,
we understand you don't want to predict
and we want to have confidence.
I think I have a fair amount of confidence
in your probability statement
that we would probably identify a sufficient number
of schools with criteria one and two.
We will want to avoid having to identify
as many as seven or 8% of schools if we can.
So if we get to that, if we have to cross that bridge,
we'll cross that bridge when we get to it.
The last question that I have is on the priority one,
the full representation of priority one
in the dashboard work plan,
which would include the percentage
of fully certified teachers,
including those who are not properly assigned
and those who are misassigned as a proportion of the total.
And is there any reason we cannot add that
to the dashboard work plan?
So it is part of the dashboard work plan.
I think folks overlooked the slide.
Maybe it would be helpful to bring it up on the screen
in which we commit to, again,
convening an ad hoc advisory group,
reporting that would provide feedback
on the reporting of the data,
including a review of the data elements.
So what I have taken from the comments
that were given today, as well as in writing,
is that there's a disagreement
about what data elements should be included,
and so we will spend time to make sure we get that right.
I think that you know very well,
because we've been meeting with you on this issue
for the last two years,
that these definitions are not clean.
And we have been spending quite a bit of time.
This is really the most complex data set
the department has ever dealt with.
And so while it's 300,000 teachers,
you're also combining that with our 6.2 million students
in the classrooms in which they're being taught.
And so that, as well as matching it up with data
that the Commission on Teacher Credentialing is giving us,
it gives us a headache, but we are working through it.
And I am confident we're gonna be able
to get some data out fairly soon.
But on the data elements piece,
we will definitely conduct a thorough review
to make sure that it is aligned
with the intent of priority one in state law.
And I'll just reiterate that,
you know, the statistic that has been reported
on this assignment is often reported alone,
but it is, and therefore it's often misunderstood
and misinterpreted.
It is the priority one states that
we should be looking at the fully credentialed teachers
who are fully credentialed in their subject area
and the proportion who are misassigned.
So in order to calculate the percentage who are misassigned,
that is they're fully credentialed,
but not properly assigned in their subject area,
you have to calculate it already,
the percentage who are fully credentialed.
So that data element is readily available,
but it's rarely reported,
and it leads to a lot of confusion in the field.
So I will just, you know, assert again
that that is a data point we have
because we couldn't calculate misassignment without it.
And that piece of it, there are more complicated elements,
which we all know about what having to do with teachers
who have various other kinds of permits
or substandard credentials.
But the element of how many are fully credentialed
from which we calculate misassignment should be,
is part of priority one,
should be part of the work plan for the department.
And with that understanding, we could move,
see if there's a motion to adopt the recommendation.
Unless there are any other questions,
I haven't seen any other hands going up.
I move to adopt the recommendation.
All right, do we have a second?
I second it.
All right, is there any further discussion?
Hearing none, Brooks, can you call the roll for the vote?
Member Rodriguez.
Yes.
Member Patilio-Brownson.
Member McQuillan.
Aye.
Member Orozco-Gonzalez.
Yes.
Member Olken.
Member Lewis.
Yes.
Vice President Glover-Woods.
Member Escobedo.
Yes.
President Darlene Hammond.
Member Bonacca.
Aye.
Motion passes.
Thank you, and thank you so much,
Cindy and Joe, for the very thorough presentation
and all of the work that has gone into
making this school year able to present data.
There were even questions about that at a moment in time,
and moving it forward in a way that is well thought through
and will inform our stakeholders.
We appreciate it.
We'll come back around on those other questions
about science and other things,
and come back to the Board with those questions on the table.
So at this point, we're just a few minutes away from noon.
I think it makes sense for us to break for lunch,
take 30 minutes, and come back at 12 22
to resume the rest of the agenda.
We'll see you then.
Remember, don't leave the meeting,
just stop your video and your mic.
Member Rodriguez.
Here.
Member Petillo-Brownson.
Member McQuillan.
Here.
Member Orozco-Gonzalez.
Present.
Member Olken.
Member Lewis.
Present.
Vice President Glover-Woods.
Here.
Member Escobedo.
President Darling-Hammond.
Here.
Member Bonacca.
All right, we are moving on to item two.
Item two is the California Assessment
of Student Performance and Progress
and the English Language Proficiency Assessments
for California,
approval of the revised student score reports
for both the 2022-23
initial English Language Proficiency Assessments
and the initial alternate
English Language Proficiency Assessments for California,
and an update on our system program activities.
And the item will be presented by Cheryl Cotton
and Mal Vang of the CDE.
Cheryl and Mal, take it away.
Superintendent Thurmond, President Darling-Hammond,
Vice President Glover-Woods, and Board members.
I'm Cheryl Cotton, Deputy Superintendent
of the Instruction, Measurement,
and Administration branch.
To assist with this item, I have Dr. Mal Vang,
Director of the Assessment Development
and Administration Division to co-present.
Dr. Linda Hooper, Associate Director
of Assessment and Administration Division.
Marion Aracilla, Executive Director
from Educational Testing Service.
Tony Alpert, Executive Director,
and Dr. Magna Chia, Chief Strategy Officer
from the Smarter Balanced Assessment Consortium
as panelists to assist us with questions.
The item before you today is an action
and an information item.
Next slide.
Today's presentation will cover the following topics.
We will provide an overview
of the California Department of Education's
CDE recommendation for approval,
as well as background information
on the action item for today.
Then we will go over some CASP and LPAC updates.
And finally, we will return to the CDE's recommendation
for SBE item.
Now we'll hand the presentation over to Dr. Mal Vang,
Director of Assessment Development
and Administration Division.
Thank you.
Superintendent Thurman, President Darling-Hammond,
Vice President Glover Woods, and board members.
As Deputy Superintendent Cotton mentioned,
I'm Mal Vang, Director for the Assessment Development
and Administration Division.
In this section, I will provide an overview
of the California Department of Education's
recommendation for approval.
So the California Department of Education recommends
that the California State Board of Education
approve the revised initial English language
proficiency assessments for California or LPAC
and the initial alternate LPAC student score reports
for the 2022-23 test results as found in attachment two.
In this next section, I will provide background information
on the action item.
In California, our California assessment system overall
as background information serves all our 6 million
plus students in kindergarten through grade 12,
including in that about 1.1 million English learners,
800,000 students with disabilities,
and 300,000 educators in about 2,000 local educational
agencies and about 10,000 schools,
while administering about 20 million tests annually.
So the California assessment of student performance
and progress or CASP here is an umbrella assessment system.
In 2010, the California State Board of Education
adopted the Common Core State Standards
for English Language Arts or ELA here, and mathematics.
So per state law, California joined
the Smarter Balanced Assessment Consortium in June 2011
as a governing state to work on the development
of English and math assessments.
The three components of the Smarter Balanced Assessments
for English Language Arts and Mathematics here
consists of the summative assessments, interim assessments,
and formative assessment resources in the Tools
for Teachers system to support instruction
and professional learning throughout the year.
Also as addressed in state law,
the CASP or summative assessments include
the following, as I mentioned,
the Smarter Balanced Summative Assessments
for English Language Arts and Mathematics,
which is administered to students
in grades three through eight and 11,
and then the California Science Test,
or we call the acronym as CAST,
which is administered to students in grades five, eight,
and ones in high school.
We also have added science resources
in the Tools for Teachers for this assessment,
to support this assessment.
And then there is the California Alternate Assessments
for English Language Arts, Mathematics, and Science.
This is for students with the most significant
cognitive disabilities as designated
in their Individualized Education Plan,
or IEP program, or IEP, excuse me.
And then we also have the California Spanish Assessment
for Spanish Reading Language Arts,
which is an optional test administered to students
in grades three through eight and high school.
And then we have the grade two Diagnostic Assessments
for English Language Arts and Mathematics
for local educational agencies
that continue to test students in grade two.
Oh, just a minute.
I wanted to just provide a little quick background
on the CASP.
So these CASP summative assessments are computer adapted
or computer-based tests that measure what students know
and can do in these content areas.
And they produce scores that can be aggregated
and disaggregated for the purpose
of informing parents and guardians,
local educational agencies, the public,
and the state about students' achievement in their learning
of the California Academic Content Standards.
So the CASP summative assessments
also provide individual student results
to students, parents and guardians, and teachers,
and produce school, district, and county level results
that allow for the monitoring of a school progress as well,
and then produce results to meet the requirements
of the Elementary and Secondary Education Act,
or ESEA, as amended by the Every Student Succeeds Act,
or ESSA, and was enacted on December 10, 2015.
The other assessment under the California Assessment System
is the English Language Proficiency Assessments
for California, or ALPAC.
So the ALPAC serves multiple purposes.
The initial ALPAC is the Required State Task
for English Language Proficiency, or ELP,
that is administered to students whose primary language
is a language other than English,
and it assesses listening, speaking, reading, and writing
to eligible students, or eligible students take this test,
or this assessment only once in their educational career.
And the purpose of the initial ALPAC, again,
is to determine the English language proficiency
of students enrolling in schools in California
for the first time.
So the process of administering the initial ALPAC
and notifying parents and guardians of the results
is completed within 30 days, calendar days,
of enrollment in a California public school.
The summative ALPAC here measures
how well English learner students are progressing
with English language development,
in each of the four domains, again,
of listening, speaking, reading, and writing.
And the purpose is to measure students' progress
towards English language proficiency.
As with the initial ALPAC, this assessment is administered
to students in kindergarten through grade 12.
Students are assessed with the summative ALPAC annually
until they meet reclassification,
or, and it also supports decisions for students
to be re-designated as fluent English proficient.
The alternate ALPAC is for English learner students
with the most significant cognitive disabilities.
Again, for students in kindergarten through grade 12,
it is used for the same purpose
as the initial and summative ALPAC.
The alternate ALPAC is aligned
to the 2012 California English Language Development
standards through the English Language Development Connectors,
which are reduced in breadth, depth, and complexity.
However, the alternate ALPAC uses integrated task types
that measure a student's expressive,
meaning speaking and writing skills,
and receptive, meaning listening and reading skills.
However, students can respond
in their preferred mode of communication
for all test questions.
So some examples of communication modes are verbal,
one-word responses, or non-verbal responses,
such as pointing, nodding, eye gaze,
and using augmentative and alternative communication devices.
And this assessment is administered one-on-one
and in person.
So we are in the middle of test administrations
for the CASP and the ALPAC.
This slide consists of the testing windows
for the administration of the CASP assessments.
The Smarter Balanced Interim Assessments
for English Language, Arts, and Math
span the whole year.
From August 17th through July 30th, they'll be available.
The California Alternate Assessment for Science
is meant to be administered directly after instruction
and is open from September 6th through July 15th.
The CASP summative assessments overall for ELA
for English Language, Arts, Mathematics, and Science,
and the alternate assessments for the same content areas,
and the optional California Spanish assessment
are available from January 11th through July 15th.
And then the ALPAC test administration windows
for this year.
The initial ALPAC window opened in July 1st,
and it will be available through June 30th.
And then due to the holiday and systems updates,
the first day of testing for next school year
will begin on July 5th.
And then we'll have the first day of testing
for next school year will begin on July 5th.
And then we have our summative ALPAC window,
which is open from February 1st
through May 31st of each year.
And then the alternate operational ALPAC,
alternate ALPAC operational field test, excuse me.
Administration window opened on November 1st of this year,
and it has been extended through May 31st, 2022.
And I'll provide a little bit more detail
about the status of our alternate ALPAC
operational field test in a later slide.
So to help with this item,
and to provide further background,
on this slide before you
is the student score reports development timeline.
And as background information,
as each test becomes operational,
we have brought the proposed student score reports
to the State Board of Education for review and approval.
So in March of 2015,
the State Board of Education approved
the 2014-15 CASP student score reports,
which was the first set of student score reports
for English, Language, Arts, and Math.
And then in January of 2016,
the State Board approved the 2015-16 CASP
student score reports for English, Language, Arts, and Math.
And then in May 2016,
the State Board of Education approved
the 2015-16 student score reports
for the California Alternate Assessments
for English and Math, that was their first year.
In December 2017, the State Board also approved
the 2017-18 student score reports
for the summative ALPAC assessment for the first time.
And then in October 2018,
we went through a period where we were transitioning
from paper to electronic student score reports.
So an information memorandum
was sent to the State Board of Education
that explained the technical edits to the score reports
and the transition from paper to electronic reports
and the timing for that and the implementation plan.
And then these technical edits and the resulting design
that was applied to the English, Language, Arts, and Math
was applied to all the CASP assessments.
And that included the ELA Math, the Science,
the California Science Test,
the California Spanish Assessment,
and the California Alternate Assessments
for English, Language, Arts, and Math.
Then in September of 2019,
the State Board approved the 2019-20 revisions
to include the California Alternate Assessment
for Science at that time.
And in addition, the revisions
to the ALPAC student score reports.
So the State Board of Education approved the 2020-21
initial ALPAC student score report in January of 2020.
And then the 2020-21
altered ALPAC student score reports in November of 2020.
So it seems like I'm going through
each of these dates with you,
but they're very important in how it kind of addresses
our timeline and what we're presenting today.
So I just wanna make sure I provide some thorough background.
And in January of this year,
the State Board of Education once again approved
the revisions to the CASP and ALPAC student score reports
for this year, the 21-22 school year.
And then finally, the CD is proposing
that the State Board of Education approve
the 2022-23 initial ALPAC
and initial alternate ALPAC student score reports today.
So in this slide, I will share the proposed revisions
for the 22-23 initial ALPAC
and initial alternate ALPAC student score reports
as found in attachment two.
The purpose is to ensure that the student score reports
reflect the most up-to-date changes
so that key information about student performance
is communicated clearly to parents and guardians.
The California Department of Education
proposes removing the alternate assessment footnote
on this initial ALPAC student score report,
updating the unlisted resource footnote
as a single asterisk and making a minor edit
to the language in the footnote.
Because the initial ALPAC,
alternate ALPAC will be operational in July,
local educational agencies will no longer need
to administer locally determined alternate assessments.
So the alternate assessment footnote is no longer needed
on the initial ALPAC student score report.
These changes are consistent
with the summative ALPAC student score reports
that were approved by the State Board of Education
in January of this year, 2022.
And in addition, based on feedback from our interest holders,
the what is the ALPAC section
has been incorporated into the why section
both initial ALPAC
and the initial alternate ALPAC student score reports
to be consistent with other student score reports.
And lastly, the performance level graphic
has been added to the overall score
and performance level box on page one
to be consistent with the summative
ALPAC student score report.
And the academic year was updated to 2022-23
on both student score reports.
So this is our mega assessment update.
So we do have some specific updates to share with you.
I'd like to go over them in this next session.
As I mentioned, I was going to go into detail a bit more
about the alternate ALPAC operational field test.
The, this operational field test,
the window again began on November 1st, 2021
and was scheduled to end on February 15th, 2022.
However, throughout the whole field test,
we monitor testing and as we wanted to make sure
that the local educational agencies were able to assess
all of our eligible English learner students
with the most significant cognitive disabilities
on this assessment.
And because not all local educational agencies
were able to complete testing,
the testing window has been extended to May 31st
to coincide with the close of the summative
ALPAC administration window as well.
And as of February 15th, approximately 60%
of the eligible students have been assessed.
So with the extension of the window,
we anticipate that the local educational agencies
will be able to assess 100% of the eligible students
as we near the end of the administration window.
We are, we conducted the standard setting workshops
with the contractor ETS and California educators
in late February and early March.
So our next steps in the development
of this alternate ALPAC will be to bring forward
the standard setting plan to the State Board of Education
via an April information memorandum
and the proposed threshold scores
to the State Board of Education's review and approval
at its May SBE meeting.
So transitioning to another update that we'd like to share
is information about the Smarter Balanced
demonstration of concept study.
So in January, the California Department of Education
did provide information regarding this study
conducted by Smarter Balanced in partnership
with the new teacher center.
And this study stems from interest expressed by leadership
in select member states in exploring the idea
of through year assessments and other efforts
to reduce the amount of time required
for summative assessments at the end of the year.
So considering these interests,
Smarter Balanced and a new teacher center
developed this study which focuses on examining
how embedding Smarter Balanced performance tasks
into classroom instruction may reduce the time required
for the end of year summative assessment process.
So due to the challenges that local educational agencies
have faced as a result of the COVID-19 pandemic,
the study is now comprised of solely two
local educational agencies in California.
Val Verde Unified School District,
which is in Riverside County,
is participating with grades four, five and six
and high school.
And Upper Lake Unified School District,
which is in Lake County,
is participating at the high school level.
The states of Washington, just as a note,
the states of Washington and Hawaii
were originally going to participate also,
but ultimately they were not able to.
So in this study as a first step for participating,
the educators were to attend an initial set
of professional learning sessions
hosted by the new teacher center.
And then leadership staff
from both the local educational agencies
met with the staff from Smarter Balanced
and the new teacher center
to create a customized professional learning plan
that will work with their instructional calendars.
And at this point in the study,
Val Verde has completed 16 of 26
planned professional learning sessions.
And Upper Lake Unified has completed seven
of the nine planned professional learning sessions.
And some additional key steps
for participating educators in this year's study
include implementing the performance task support activity
and then administering the performance task, of course,
and collaborating with colleagues
in scoring student responses
and then planning for instruction based on data gathered.
So this year's study is expected to conclude in May, 2022
with a report to follow and further investigation
to this area is anticipated for the 2022-23 school year.
More information will be provided
in our CASP update section of the May SBE item.
So this brings me to the close of the presentation slides.
I want to remind you to follow us on Twitter
at CDE assessments to get some latest updates
on all the development
and administration activities we're doing.
And at this time, I'm happy to pause
and see if you have any clarifying questions
that I may address at this time.
Thank you so much, Mel.
And could you put the call-in slide in up
so that anyone who wants to queue up
for a public comment can do so.
And I'll just remind folks
that they can make a public comment
by calling the number and dialing the access code
on this slide.
And then while we're waiting for members of the public
to call in, I'll share a couple of comments
and then see if we have clarifying questions.
And I see member Rodriguez is waiting with one.
First, I just want to thank Mel
for all the work that has gone on,
not just in the last couple of months,
but over this last year,
trying to help us get through the process
of doing assessments in the pandemic,
just Yeoman's effort and two good results.
And the end of that process is happening now
as we sort of make sure that everything
is ready to move forward in a more,
I hate to say normal,
because that word has taken on so many connotations,
but in a more systematic way.
So thank you very much for that.
I think that the proposals here make a lot of sense.
I'm particularly excited to hear more in May
about the proof of concept that Smarter Balanced
is engaged in with the performance tests
being used in the classroom during the school year.
And we'll look forward to hearing more about that.
And we'll turn to clarifying questions.
Iday, you are first up.
All right, thank you.
And thank you so much for this item.
I really enjoyed the graphics and your presentation
and the item itself.
And I just have a clarifying question regarding,
and it may be something that you covered
or that has been covered before,
but the SSRs, when they go home to the parents,
are they also available to the parents
in their home language?
Yes, we do translate them into the top seven languages
in California, so they are available.
Thank you for that.
You're welcome.
Any other clarifying questions
before we go to public comment?
Seeing none, we'll open the public comment line.
Do we have any public comments?
Yes, we do.
It looks like we have two people signed up
for public comment.
I will open the phone line now.
Good afternoon, State Board of Education.
Please state your name and affiliation for the record.
You have one minute.
Your time starts now.
I am Martha Hernandez at Californians Together,
and we endorse the approval of the revised student report
for both 2022-23 initial LPAC
and initial alternate LPAC.
We want to express our appreciation
for the revisions on the reports for both the forms
to include the information on what is
and why do we administer the initial LPAC.
We are grateful for the opportunity
to have provided input and collaborate with CDE staff
on the new version of the form.
Thank you very much.
Thank you.
Next caller, please state your name
and affiliation for the record.
Your time starts now.
Good afternoon.
Liz Guillen at Public Advocates for the Equity Coalition.
We want to support this item,
and we also wanted to take the opportunity
to thank the department staff
for hearing the concerns that we raised
about the student score reports
and making the changes that we recommended.
We think it's going to be helpful for parents
as they try to make sense of all this information.
And we also think it's important that whenever we can,
that we thank our colleagues at the department
for all the hard work that they're doing.
Thank you.
Bye-bye.
That concludes public comment for item number two.
I just think it's lovely that we get public comments
thanking people for being so responsive to public input
and recognizing the efforts of the departments.
So just like to launch us into a good discussion
of this item with that observation,
are there any other questions or comments
from folks about this item?
Yes, Member Bonacca.
I have a quick clarifying question
in terms of the Smarter Balanced Demonstration
of Concept Study.
So if I'm understanding it correctly,
teachers are embedding performance tasks
in the classroom instruction
as a way to prepare for the test, correct?
Ultimately, it might be the way
that the test is actually given
rather than doing it all at one time at the end.
But I see that Tony Alpert has just popped up
on the screen.
Hi, Tony.
Do you want to respond to that question?
Absolutely.
So thank you for the question.
Ultimately, we want teachers to provide
to improve student learning
and to address the skills
that the performance tests measure.
So the demonstration of concept
gives a little bit of flexibility
as to when the A task might be administered,
currently the interim assessment task,
and so that teachers can better fit the task
with their instructional plan,
but ultimately gives a lot of guidance
and support and structure
regarding the higher order thinking skills
that the performance has addressed
and helps guide the teachers
in how they can provide students
with the scaffolding to bring their background
and their assets into a instructional discussion
that better helps students acquire those skills.
We anticipate that students will do better
on the summit of assessment,
but the primary purpose
is to improve teaching and learning.
And let me just say that
there are more than 20 states
around the country right now
that are looking at different ways
of organizing assessment.
Having been through the pandemic
and everyone trying to figure out
how do we give our assessments at the end of the year,
but also feeling a need for information
that informs teaching and learning throughout the year.
There are a number of states
that are in one way or another
looking at methods to do assessment
that would allow assessments
during the course of the school year
to be part of both informing instruction
and potentially to be rolled up as part of the score,
rather than doing all of that at the end of the year,
which for us,
because we have performance tasks in our assessments,
which we're proud of and happy about,
would allow shortening those assessments
significantly at the end of the year as well.
So it is at the moment a way to test the concept.
It's a proof of concept.
Could we embed these tests in instruction?
How do they work?
How do teachers and students feel about that process?
And then is there an implication for the end of the year?
But so the folks who are engaged in the pilot
will give the interim performance tests now
and will also still see performance tests
in their end of year assessment this year.
Got it.
Thank you for the clarification.
And just one more clarification.
So if they're taking these tasks throughout the year,
do teachers, if I'm understanding this correctly,
get the data from those assessments
and they're able to modify their learning
to kind of fill any gaps in knowledge that they see,
or is that data not available?
Kerry?
So the interim assessments provide data
pretty much immediately.
In the case of the performance test,
it requires that someone, typically the teacher,
complete hand scoring,
and then the results are available in the CSRS,
the California Educator Reporting System,
which they can then use in a couple of different ways.
They can look at the students' responses.
They can look at all the students' responses in the class.
They can connect to tools for teachers to find resources
that address the same skills
and think about whether or not they can,
they need to retool their instruction
or enhance or address specific concepts.
They also have access
to our annotated student response viewer,
where they can see exemplar papers at each performance level
and get an idea of where their student performance fits in
with the rubric based on similar students' writings.
And so part of the discussion then is,
all that is available with the interim assessments.
What is, as Linda was describing,
we still have to think about then,
how do we transport that into a summative type environment
where similar flexibility and benefits are available?
But right now, we're getting feedback on,
is this at all helpful?
And so far, the results are promising.
Got it, thank you for that clarification.
And I can just say, as a student,
I know that when my teachers kind of have implemented
a similar type of teaching where we take tasks,
like for example, tests, I know for my IB tests,
we've done this a lot.
We take mock exams and they grade it
and they kind of go back and teach us the things that,
they kind of fill in those gaps in knowledge.
And I've found that it's been just extremely helpful.
It really helped me, especially last year with my IB exams,
and right now I'm using that method this year as well.
So I'm really glad that we're studying this.
And as you know, with an IB program,
you're taking some papers and projects
during the school year that are being scored
and taking some exams that are being scored
and it all gets combined into an analysis.
So it's actually sort of a type of analog.
Member Glover-Woods.
Yes, clarifying question around the calibration
of the scoring related to the performance tasks.
So how in this pilot are the scores
that teachers are giving to the performance tasks
calibrated from class to class
and with the schools that are participating in the study?
If I may answer that,
that's an incredibly important and complicated question.
So we provide the task,
all the interim assessment items are field tested
during the summative assessment.
And it is an intel after field testing is completed
and we've looked at the quality of the statistics
associated with the items that we then determine
whether or not those items go into the interim
or the summative.
So, but they all meet the same rigorous quality criteria.
And so that's how we calibrate from a statistical sense
as to the relative difficulty of items.
Then regarding scoring as each performance task
is associated with papers, we call anchor papers
that help orient the teacher on the requisite knowledge
of skills that students need to demonstrate
for a particular prompt and what the associated level
of the rubric that performance would be associated with.
And teachers can look at those
and they can go through a process independently
to calibrate their own scoring
against these pre-scored papers.
During the demonstration of concept,
the new teacher center is providing embedded
and ongoing coaching and helping teachers
understand the rubric, understand the content standards
associated with the performance task
that the performance task is measuring
and then helping guide them on that critical process
of calibrating their own evaluation
based on these other resources.
And so that is a substantial enhancement
into the process that we think is both extremely helpful
and also essential as we increase the complexity
of the summative assessment
and give that additional flexibility to teachers.
So let me just also note that this experiment,
if you will, this proof of concept
does not count at all in our end of year testing this year.
This is an opportunity to see how it goes in classrooms
and some of those teachers are scoring the students work.
I think there may be some who opted out of scoring
and other teachers are scoring the work
and who are trained scorers
because we do for our assessments,
trained scores routinely who are teachers.
And so they get the scores from someone else's scoring,
but this is all for the purpose of learning at the moment.
If we were ever to do something like this
as part of the summative,
there would be a training process,
there would be a calibration process,
there would probably be a back read and audit process
that would take place as is common
when you use performance tasks.
And as happens with the performance tasks now
that are in the end of year exam.
Any other questions?
All right, well, thank you very much.
Thanks for coming, Tony.
Nice to see you.
Not a very long trip.
I think you might have gone from your kitchen
to your living room, but to get online.
And Mal, thank you for all the good work that you've done.
I don't, I guess we do need a motion.
Yes, to accept the new changes to the score reports.
Do I have a motion on that?
I move.
And here's the recommendation for approval.
I assume you're moving this recommendation.
And do we have a second?
Second.
Thank you very much.
Any further discussion?
Brooks, would you like to call the roll?
Member Rodriguez.
Yes.
Member Petillo-Brownson.
Member McQuillan.
Aye.
Member Orozco-Gonzalez.
Yes.
Member Olken.
Member Lewis.
Yes.
Vice President Glover-Woods.
Member Escobedo.
Yes.
President Darling-Hammond.
Member Bonacca.
Aye.
Motion passes.
Thank you.
I move right along to item three,
which is the Federal Every Student Succeeds Act,
Authorization to Pursue a Waiver
for the 2021-22 school year of the 1% cap
on the percentage of eligible students
with the most significant cognitive disabilities
who may be assessed with an alternate assessment
aligned with alternate academic achievement standards
for English language arts, mathematics,
and science or other related waivers.
And this item will be presented
by Cheryl Cotton and Mal Vang.
Glad you didn't go far.
And Cheryl, we're not hearing you yet,
just to let you know.
Superintendent Thurmond,
President Darling-Hammond,
Vice President Glover-Woods,
and board members, I'm Cheryl Cotton,
again, Deputy Superintendent
of the Instruction, Measurement, and Administration branch.
To assist with this item,
I have Dr. Mal Vang,
Director of Assessment Development
and Administration Division to co-present,
Dr. Linda Hooper,
Associate Director of Assessment and Administration Division,
and Shiloh Duncan-Berserill,
Associate Director of the Special Education Division
as panelists to assist us with questions.
The item before you today is an action and information item.
A revised version of item three
was posted on March 3rd to update the following.
On page four of the item
and page 16 of attachment one,
we provided language to clarify
how California intends to meet the 90-day requirement
to submit a waiver request of the 1% cap
on eligible students
with the most significant cognitive disabilities
who may be assessed with an alternate assessment
for the 22-23 school year.
On page eight of attachment one,
the updated estimates were provided
in tables eight and nine,
based on recent registration data.
Today's presentation covers the recommendation for approval
of and background on this action item request
to the United States Department of Education, or ED.
Today's presentation will cover the following topics.
We'll provide an overview
of the California Department of Education's
recommendation for approval,
as well as background information
on the action item for today.
Then we will go over some of the CASP and LPAC updates.
And finally, we will return to the CDE's recommendation
for SBE action.
Now I will hand the presentation over to Dr. Mao Vang,
Director of the Assessment Development
and Administration Division.
Thank you, Cheryl.
Again, Superintendent Thurman, President Arlen Hammond,
Vice President Glover-Woods, and board members.
I'm Mao Vang.
I'm Director of the Assessment Development
and Administration Division.
In this section, I will provide an overview
of CDE's recommendation for approval.
And just to clarify, I may have
note that the recommendation here is
that the CDE recommends that the California State Board
of Education authorize the California Department
of Education to submit to the U.S. Department of Education
the draft waiver package found in attachment one,
which contains the following.
A request for a waiver of the requirement to assess 95%
of students in the 2020-21 school year.
Request for a waiver of the requirement
that these waiver requests be submitted at least 90 days
before the beginning of our annual testing window.
And request for a waiver of the requirement
to assess less than 1% of eligible students
with an alternate assessment for the 21-22 administration.
Furthermore, we are asking for a request
for an extension of our plan
to report preliminary indicator results
for the 2021 administration
of the California alternate assessment for science.
As background information, the State Board of Education
has the authority to request waivers
for federal requirement as the designated
state education agency.
And that is why we are bringing this up to you.
And then just going over the background information
regarding the requirements for the state education.
Information regarding our recommendation.
This per, excuse me, per our federal regulations,
which is really Section 200.6C2.
The total number of students assessed
using an alternate assessment
aligned with alternate academic achievement standards
may not exceed 1% of the total number
of students assessed in the state.
So if the state expects that it will exceed 1%
of students assessed with alternate assessments,
the state needs to request a waiver of this requirement.
So in order for a state to be eligible
for the waiver of the 1% cap on alternate assessments,
it must assess at least 95% of all students enrolled
as well as 95% of students with this,
in the students with disabilities group
in the previous year.
Furthermore, a request of a waiver of 1%,
of the 1% cap requirement must be submitted 90 days
before the beginning of the state's annual testing window.
So the CASP summative testing window
opened on January 11th, 2022.
So as a result, there is a memo
from the US Department of Education
on October, dated October 29th, 2021,
regarding this 1% cap waiver.
And the extended options to states
to meet this requirement in light of the impact
of the COVID pandemic in the 2020-21 school year.
So based on CDE or California Department of Education's
data analysis and survey results
from local educational agencies,
the California Department of Education anticipates
that California will exceed the 1% cap for the 2021-22.
And so the waiver package that the CDE wishes
to submit with the State Board of Education's approval
involves a waiver of the 1% cap,
as well as other waivers determined to be necessary
due to the unique situation surrounding state testing
throughout the pandemic.
And I will cover each of these waivers
in more detail in these slides.
So the first waiver is the participation rate of 95%
for the 2020-21 school year.
So as I mentioned, in order for a state to be eligible
for a waiver of the 1% cap on alternate assessments,
it must have assessed at least 95% of students enrolled
as well as 95% of students with disabilities
in the previous year.
And the Ed did invite states to request a waiver
of the 95% participation rate requirement for the 2020-21.
And although our state, California,
offered all of our statewide assessments
in the 2020-21 school year,
California did not meet the 95% participation rate.
And this excludes the students who took local assessments
as they are not counted toward the 95% participation rate.
So due to the fact that California did not meet
this 95% participation requirement
in the 2020-21 school year,
and meeting this participation rate is required
for applying for the waiver of the 1% cap
on alternate assessments,
the CDE is requesting the SBE's authorization
to request a waiver of the requirement
to assess 95% of students in the 2020-21 school year.
The second waiver, the 90-day timeline
for request of the 1% waiver.
The deadline, of course, from federal law
is for requesting a waiver of these requirements
to assess the less than 1% of students
with an alternate assessment is that 90 days
prior to the beginning of testing,
again, because the testing window for the CAS has begun,
the California Department of Education
cannot meet this timeline.
And for this reason,
the California Department of Education
requests the SBE's authorization to request
for a waiver of the requirement
that these waiver requests be submitted 90 days
before the beginning of the state's annual testing window.
So as a reminder, as Cheryl mentioned,
a revised version of the item was posted on March 3rd
with updates on page four of the item
and page 16 of attachment one,
with language to clarify how California intends
to meet the 90-day requirement in the coming school year,
the 2022-23 school year.
So to meet the requirement in the 2022-23 school year,
the California Department of Education
will analyze the data from this spring's administration,
2022, and if California is projected to exceed
the 1% cap, the CDE will bring to the SBE
a waiver request for exceeding the 1% cap
on eligible students taking alternate assessments in July
to give us that time allotment to do so.
The third waiver is the 1% cap
on students being assigned the alternate assessment
for the 2021-22 school year.
So the California Department of Education
has collected surveys from local educational agencies
regarding their expectations of number of eligible students
participating in alternate assessments
for the 2021-22 school year.
And we have also reviewed alternate assessment
participation data from the 2018-19
as well as the 2020-21 school year.
And the California Department of Education
anticipates and expects that the state will exceed
the 1% cap on the percentage of our eligible students
with the most significant cognitive disabilities
who may be assessed with an alternate assessment
for the 2021-22 school year.
And for this reason, the CDE requests the SBE's
authorization to submit the waiver of the 1% cap
for the 2021-22 school year.
And on the following slides,
I will review some of the participation rate data
included in the CDE's waiver requests package
to the US Department of Education.
So this table consists of the California
alternate assessment participation rate
of eligible students with disabilities
by content area, ELA, English language arts,
mathematics, and science for the 2020-21 school year.
So the data indicates that English language arts
and mathematics exceeded the 1% threshold
and science was very close to the 1%.
And this table shows the estimated number
of eligible students
for the California alternate assessments,
participation rates again by English language arts,
mathematics, and science in the 2020-22 school administration.
And it's based on enrollment and registration.
And the estimated number of students assessed
with the California alternate assessments
to meet the 95% participation rate.
Again, as a reminder, the revised version of the item
that was posted on March 3rd on page eight of attachment one,
the updated estimates were provided in tables eight and nine
based on recent registration data.
And then the estimated overall CAA participation rates,
this one is the estimated overall participation rates
for all students, and this one is the estimated
participation rates for all students
and for this spring's test of 2022 spring administration.
This table shows the estimated number
of eligible students overall
for English language arts, mathematics, and science
and the estimated number of students
who need to be assessed to meet the 95% participation rate.
Overall, the data from recent years and estimates
for the 2022 administration indicates
that California should request a waiver of the 1% cap
on the percentage of eligible students
with the most significant cognitive disabilities
who may be assessed with an alternate assessment
for the 2021-22 school year for English language arts,
mathematics, and science.
And then switching again to more further background
on the next topic is requesting an extension
to use the preliminary indicators for reporting results
of the 2021 California alternate assessments for science.
The, in the 2019-20 school year,
California Department of Education did plan that
to be the California alternate science assessment
for science's administration
to be the first operational field test operational year.
However, due to the COVID pandemic,
again, testing was suspended
and the first California alternate assessment
for science operational field test was delayed for one year.
And then during the 2020-21 school year,
the California alternate assessment
for science administration due to the continued impact
of the COVID pandemic,
there was a limited number of eligible students
who were eligible for the 2021 school year
and students who completed testing.
Therefore, the California Department of Education
delayed the operational administration of the test
for another year.
So California is now requesting
that the State Board of Education
authorize the California Department of Education
to request from the US Department of Education
an extension to use the preliminary indicator results
for the 2020-21 administration.
For the California alternate assessment for science.
And that summarizes each of the ask
or request for waivers or request for extension
that are in this item.
And it brings me to the summary slide here.
So I will just remind you about our little Twitter account
and following us, and I will pause for
and answer any clarifying questions that you may have.
Running back to you, President.
Thank you, I appreciate the little PR plug
for the Twitter account.
And I'll just say we have a hot water heater
being replaced here.
So I've been kind of on and off screen a little bit.
And if I disappear, Vice President Glover Woods
will be taking the gavel.
So we're just keeping up with business today.
Could you put up the public comment slides
so that we can have callers queue up for public comment?
And I will see if any of you in the board
will have any clarifying questions
while we're waiting for public comment.
And simply say that this is very helpful information.
Mal, we appreciate it.
And I don't have any particular concerns
or questions myself.
So any clarifying questions?
Yes, Member Glover Woods.
And again, definitely support the need for the waiver.
Just Mal clarifying question on why we were not able
to meet the 90 day window for the 2021,
2020, 2021 school year.
Yeah, so last school year we did,
the board did approve us to extend the testing window
all the way to the end of July for both CASP and ALPAC.
So we didn't, that also extended when we could have
all the data available.
And we worked through the fall.
So we did not publicly release our data
until January 7th of 2022.
So all the delays did not give us the information
in a timely manner to be able to submit the waiver.
And I think the Department of Education
will understand all of that because there were states
across the country that were urged
to extend their testing windows
if that would be enabling for the field.
So we're not alone in that circumstance.
That's right.
Any other clarifying questions?
All right, is there any public comment?
We do not have anybody in the queue
for public comments for this item.
All right, since there's no public comment,
we can see if there's any further board discussion.
And if there is no further board discussion,
we can take a motion.
And maybe Mal, you wanna, oh, yes, Member McClellan.
Yes, just to follow up.
Thank you for this presentation.
Very technical, a lot of information there.
So there have been other states
who have been already granted extensions
and waivers in this area.
That was kind of one of my questions.
Thank you.
Yes, in terms of submitting them,
I don't know whether they are approved,
but yes, it's a process
that the U.S. Department of Education has available.
So it depends on state's readiness.
They submit it when they can.
Yeah, and the point I was making was simply
that many states did extend their testing windows
last year as we did.
And so then you can't calculate
what your percentage of engagement was until later.
And so we will not be alone in that,
but we don't know whether anybody else
has been granted a waiver,
but the department will not be surprised
by these kinds of requests.
Any other discussion questions or comments?
All right, do we have a motion
to accept the board's recommendation
or the department's recommendation?
I'll move to accept the recommendation on the screen.
All right, and a second?
I second.
Thank you.
Any further discussion?
Brooks, can you call the roll for the vote?
Member Rodriguez?
Yes.
Member Petillo-Brownson?
Member McQuillan?
Yes.
Member Orozco-Gonzalez?
Member Olken?
Member Lewis?
Yes.
Vice President Glover-Woods?
Member Escobedo?
Yes.
President Darling-Hammond?
Member Bonacca?
Aye.
Motion carries.
All right, thank you very much.
We're gonna move right on ahead into item five.
Item five is the Eagle Collegiate Academy.
We are to consider evidence regarding a notice
of violation issued by the California State Board
of Education pursuant to California Education Code
Section 47607G, and we will consider issuing a notice
of intent to revoke with notice of facts pursuant
to California Education Code Section 47607H.
And I'm gonna allow Stephanie Farland of the CDE
to present the recommendation and the background.
President Darling-Hammond, I think we need just a moment here
for Ms. Farland to connect.
All right, we will.
There we go.
Thank you.
Oh, cool, and your hand is still up.
Is that just left over from before?
There we go.
Thanks.
For stretching my arm.
Figuratively.
President Darling-Hammond, I believe we're ready to proceed.
All right, Stephanie, please proceed.
Thank you.
Good afternoon, President Darling-Hammond, board members,
Chief Deputy Mary Nicely.
Good to see all of you.
Today we are onto item five, and this item consists
of the consideration of evidence regarding the notice
of violation that was issued to Eagle Collegiate Academy
by the California State Board of Education
on January 12th, 2022.
CDE recommends that the state board issue a notice
of intent to revoke and notice of facts in support
of the revocation of Eagle Collegiate Academy
charter school.
Just a little background.
At its July 8th, 9th, 2020 meeting,
the state board approved the Eagle Collegiate
charter petition on appeal with conditions
to establish a new school within the boundaries
of the Acton-Aguadose Unified School District
with a scheduled opening date in 2021-22.
So part of the conditions were that the school
had an additional year to open.
The charter petition stated its intention
to serve 168 students in TK through grade three
in its first year of operation.
So here we have a timeline of board action.
This means local and county boards.
So we know November of 2019,
the Eagle Collegiate Academy petition was denied
by the Acton-Aguadose Unified School District
by a vote of five to zero.
It then went on appeal to the Los Angeles County
Board of Education where they voted to deny
on a vote of six to zero.
It then came up to the State Board of Education on appeal.
It was heard by the ACCS,
the Advisory Commission on Charter Schools.
And the ACCS concurred with CDE's recommendation
to deny the Eagle Collegiate Academy petition
by a vote of seven to one with one abstention.
It then came to the board, State Board,
where the State Board approved it with conditions
to establish a new school within the boundaries
of Acton-Aguadose School District.
In September, the ECA opened virtually
because they had yet to obtain a facility.
On November 12th, 2021,
the CDE sent a letter of concern
to the Eagle Collegiate Academy.
That letter of concern was based on a report
that the school had only 12 students enrolled.
That letter of concern then,
on January 12th, the SBE issued a notice of violation
as they didn't remedy the issues in the letter of concern.
And on February 15th, the ACCS, as I stated earlier,
concurred with the CDE's recommendation
and unanimously voted to recommend
that the SBE issue a notice of intent to revoke
to Eagle Collegiate Academy.
And just as some background,
I know we have some new members today.
So the Advisory Commission on Charter Schools
is the Advisory Commission for this body,
and they hear all of the charter items
prior to the State Board hearing the items,
and they issue their own recommendation,
apart from the CDE's recommendation.
And to go over what are the grounds
for revocation of a charter school.
Per Education Code 47607F, a charter may be revoked
if substantial evidence indicates
that the charter school did any of the following.
Committed a material violation of any of the conditions,
standards, or procedures set forth in the charter.
Failed to meet or pursue any of the pupil outcomes
identified in the charter.
Failed to meet generally accepted accounting principles
or engage in fiscal mismanagement,
or violation of any law.
So there is a process outlined in Ed Code
for revocation.
This process is not something that the department
creates, we go by the Ed Code.
So pursuant to 47607G, before revocation,
a chartering authority shall notify the charter school
of any violation and give the school
an opportunity to remedy the violation.
On January 12th, the SBE, 2022,
the SBE issued that notice of violation to ECA
and provided the school a reasonable opportunity
to remedy the violations.
ECA had failed to adequately refute remedy
or propose to remedy the violations described
in the notice of violation.
Pursuant to Ed Code 47607H, before revoking a charter
for failure to remedy a violation,
the chartering authority shall provide
a written notice of intent to revoke,
and notice of facts in support of revocation
to the charter school.
And that's what we are doing today.
At today's meeting, the SBE will consider the evidence
regarding the notice of violation
and decide whether to issue a notice of intent
to revoke and notice of facts in support
of the revocation of ECA charter.
Pursuant, and then the final step, is the public hearing.
So pursuant to Ed Code section 47607H,
no later than 30 days after providing that notice
of intent to revoke, the chartering authority
shall hold a public hearing regarding whether
evidence exists to revoke the charter.
No later than 30 days, the chartering authority
shall issue a final decision to revoke
or decline to revoke the charter.
The chartering authority shall not revoke a charter
unless it makes written factual findings
supported by substantial evidence.
At tomorrow's March 10th, 2022 meeting,
the SBE may decide to hold a public hearing
to consider the revocation of ECA charter
and issue a final decision to revoke
or decline to revoke the charter.
The CDE's recommendation is that the State Board
issue a notice of intent to revoke
and notice of facts to ECA pursuant to Ed Code 47607H.
The CDE will provide substantial evidence
that ECA has committed the following.
Fiscal mismanagement, violation of several conditions,
standards or procedures set forth in the charter,
and violation of provisions of law.
At its February 15th, 2022 meeting,
the ACCS concurred with the CDE's recommendation
and unanimously voted to recommend
that the SBE issue a notice of intent to revoke.
Just as a summary of the ACCS meeting
and the discussion that took place,
ACCS expressed its concerns with EGLE Collegiate,
which were primarily focused on the following.
Failure to meet enrollment projections,
significant overstaffing,
fiscally insolvent beyond recovery,
and inability to implement the program.
So now we'll move into the instances of violation.
The instances of violation that we have found
are fiscal mismanagement,
the budget is based on unrealistic enrollment,
and there is a projected fiscal insolvency.
There were material violations
based on Ed Code section 47607F1,
failure to maintain adequate budget reserves,
failure to timely acquire appropriate facilities,
and a change to a non-classroom based educational program.
And then the violations of law
would be the inadequate budget reserves
and non-compliant independent study written agreements.
We're gonna start with the fiscal mismanagement
because I'm sure as you read in the item,
this is the most serious of the violations
and the violation that really cannot be remedied
at this time.
As cited in the Notice of Violation,
ECA based and continues to base its budget
on an unrealistic enrollment.
And we have here just a little timeline
of the enrollment of ECA.
When they were approved,
they outlined a prospective enrollment of 168 students.
In May of 2021,
ECA reported a prospective enrollment of 131 students.
ECA reported an estimated October enrollment
of 168 students via the pupil estimates
for new or significantly expanding charters, PENSEC.
And that is the way that new charters project
how many students they'll have enrolled
and that is what their LCFF is based on, their projection.
In September of 2021,
ECA communicated that the school began
with an enrollment of 131 students.
In the beginning of November 2021,
ECA reported a total enrollment of 12 students
via the charter school 20 day attendance report.
Once we saw that report
and saw that they only had 12 students,
we immediately sent a letter of concern to the school
in early November.
As of today or as of February,
but I believe as of today,
the reported ADA continues to be 12 students.
So ECA responded to this violation
and I will go over ECA's response
and then our response to their response.
So ECA responded to this violation
by providing CDE a revised budget.
Their revised budget included their projection
of enrolling 45 new students by April 19th, 2022.
ECA stated that it anticipates
that these students will enroll
once a facility is secured.
That would give them a total of 57 students.
With 57 students enrolled,
ECA anticipates having an ADA of 27.53,
which reduces this local control funding formula
over payment from 497,000 to 329,000
for fiscal year 2021-22.
Their revised budget also includes
decreased enrollment projections
over the next couple of years from where they started out.
Our analysis of that revised budget
that came in post notice of violation
is that even if we used ECA's own projections,
which we disagree with,
we don't believe that they would be able
to get 57 students by next month.
We're in March of a school year.
But even if we went with their projections,
they still maintain a negative ending fund balance
of 302,000 at the end of fiscal year 2021-22.
We also still believe that the projected enrollment
they have for the next two years, fiscal years,
are unrealistic and inconsistent,
not only with their own growth patterns,
but with growth patterns in other charter schools.
As stated in the notice of violation,
ECA based its fiscal solvency
on an unrealistic and overestimated enrollment.
ECA responded to this violation, as I said,
by providing a revised budget.
With their own projections,
they estimate that they'll have an ending cash balance
of $4,000 for fiscal year 2021-22.
Our analysis of their revised budget
is that ECA is not fiscally sustainable.
ECA's revised budget includes a deficit of $282,497
and a negative ending fund balance of 302,000.
They also project that their public charter school
grant program funds will be allocated to them.
Their public charter school grant program funds
currently are on a payment hold.
There is an enrollment minimum
in order to receive and participate
in the federal public charter school grant program.
They are nowhere near that minimum,
and they would have to be up to 75 students
by the end of the school year
in order for the department to reissue
any money from those funds.
They are unlikely, that grant, oops, sorry,
went forward faster than I wanted to.
Those funds are unlikely to be restarted for the school.
In addition, ECA includes in their budget,
proposed budget,
elementary and secondary school emergency relief funds,
we know them as ESSER funds,
and ECA is not eligible for those funds
this year or next year,
as they do not have enough FRPM students enrolled this year,
they need at least 37,
and as I said, they only have 12 students total,
to be eligible.
And so we did verify that yesterday with our ESSER folks
that they will not be eligible for that funding.
So ECA has failed to take steps to balance its budget
also by adequately reducing expenditures.
And that is something that the ACCS discussed
in their meeting in terms of over staffing.
They have four and a half staff for 12 kids.
So really we feel like they have failed
to take the steps to balance their budget.
So the CDE's practice is to evaluate fiscal solvency
based on a school's actual enrollment.
So the budgets that were submitted by ECA
are based on the enrollment they project they will have
by the middle of April.
Our analysis is based on their actual enrollment
of 12 students.
Based on those 12, of enrolling only 12 students,
the CDE estimates that ECA's LCF repayment
will be 497,973.
And I don't know that I mentioned this before,
but the reason we keep talking about repayment
is the first LCFF payment that ECA received
was based on their 168 projection enrollment
during the PENSEC.
So they received that money, but they only had 12 students.
So they were overpaid by almost half a million dollars.
And that money is owed back to the state.
So I'm sorry if I didn't make that clear,
but when we talk about repayment,
it is the LCFF repayment, overpayment that was given
to them earlier this school year.
In the ECA's report, you will notice
that they have discussed having a repayment plan
for that overpayment.
They put in their budget that they could repay
that overpayment over the next two years.
And I wanna be really clear that a charter school
cannot dictate a repayment plan
for an overpayment of apportionment.
And the CDE nor the SBE have the authority
to grant a repayment plan for charter school overpayments.
So the school will be invoiced
and they will be required to pay that invoice at once.
ECA may have a negative ending cash balance
of $488,353 by June of 2022.
ECA will fail to meet its financial obligations
by May of 2022.
And financial obligations obviously include
teacher salaries, teacher health benefits,
teacher retirement.
If operations continue,
apportionment payments begin in July 2022
will also be offset to recover any remaining LCFF payments,
which means that even if the school stays open,
they will not receive any new LCFF funding
even next year until that overpayment is made
back to the state.
So this chart just sort of puts it out in black and white
on a chart of what our analysis is of their cash balance
and their ending fund balance
at the end of the 21-22 fiscal year.
On March 4th, which was last Friday,
ECA submitted another revised budget to the CDE.
We have conducted a preliminary review of that budget.
It just came in on Friday,
so we didn't have time to do a deep dive,
but we did look at it quickly
and based upon our preliminary review,
the CDE finds that ECA remains fiscally unsustainable.
So violations of the charter.
Failure to maintain adequate budget reserves.
As stated in the Notice of Violation,
per the MOU between ECA and the State Board,
ECA is expected to maintain reserves
at 5% of expenditures or 71,000, whichever is greater.
At the time of the Notice of Violation,
the CDE projected ECA to have a negative ending fund balance
of $1.2 million, so obviously there's not a reserve there.
ECA responded to this violation
by providing a revised budget,
but their own projections
end in a negative fund balance of $302,000,
so obviously there's a difference there
between our two analyses,
but either way, they're in a negative fund balance.
CDE analyzed the revised budget.
Again, we find their projections
to be based on unrealistic, unsubstantiated,
and inflated enrollment for 21-22.
And CDE projects that based on ECA's current enrollment
of 12 students, they will have
a negative ending fund balance of 598,000 by June 2022.
And really, that actually is probably a little higher
because we were including their ESSER funds
in some of our analysis,
but since we found out
that they're not actually entitled to ESSER funds,
those numbers go up just a little bit.
Failure to acquire appropriate facilities.
As stated in the Notice of Violation,
ECA's charter required ECA school facilities
to be completed and ready on or before May 28th, 2021.
Remember, they were approved July, 2020.
They were given an extra year to open,
so they had an extra year
to find an appropriate facility for their students.
They failed to open a facility
as a classroom-based charter school by the SBE approved date
or before the start of the fiscal year 21-22.
They started school on September 7th,
they still did not have a facility.
On December 6th, 2021, ECA informed the CDE
after we had sent the letter of concern
that it had obtained a short-term lease
at a temporary facility.
We expedited, we were down there within days,
we expedited a visit to the facility
and inspected it on December 16th
and found the facility to be non-compliant.
ECA responded to this violation
by proposing to hold class
in a different building
located on the same property of the lease site.
They notified us of that
after the notice of violation was submitted
or approved by the State Board of Education in January.
So once again, we expedited a second visit
to inspect the new building
of the newly proposed facility on February 10th.
The CDE pre-opening site inspection checklist
for this newly proposed facility
is linked under the documentation
considered by the ACCS section in the item.
What our facilities division found
was that the facility was still out of compliance
and we still had several outstanding concerns
about that facility,
which are all written in that report.
Additionally, the newly proposed facility
is located within two nautical miles of an airport runway.
Pursuant to Ed Code 17215,
before acquiring Title II or leasing property
for a new school site,
a charter school shall give the CDE written notice
of the proposed acquisition or lease
and shall submit any information required by the CDE
if the site is within two miles measured by airline
of that point on an airport runway
that is nearest to the site.
Pursuant to the same Ed Code 17215C,
the California Department of Transportation, Caltrans,
is required to evaluate that proposed K-12 school site
as they are any K-12 school site
that are within two nautical miles of an airport runway.
So to be clear,
Eagle Collegiate Academy did not do its due diligence.
The school is required to submit this information
prior to leasing the property
and prior to using any public funds for that property.
This did not happen.
Once we learned that there was an airport runway
within two nautical miles of that charter,
CDE submitted a request for this evaluation to Caltrans.
We are in the process of their review
and have not received any formal letter
approving that process.
So students cannot occupy the site
until the Caltrans findings are officially reported.
In addition, the facility is insufficient
to accommodate ECA's projected student enrollment.
So if they get the approval from Caltrans
and they remedy the deficiencies
that CDE still has with the site,
the site will only hold a maximum of 34 students
and ECA is projecting, as I said earlier,
a minimum of 57 by the end of this school year.
So the newly proposed facility
will not accommodate this projected enrollment level,
even if it becomes compliant.
And the facility is a temporary lease, as I said earlier.
The facility is only leased
through the end of this school year
and the school does not have a site for next year.
As outlined in the notice of violation,
ECA's petition outlines a classroom-based
international baccalaureate educational program.
However, ECA has reported that its students
are receiving online instruction only
via independent study.
ECA responded to this violation
by stating that its curriculum has not changed,
it has been forced to conduct instruction virtually
due to challenges in obtaining a facility.
We're not disagreeing with that,
but it is a violation of their petition
in that they were only approved
for an online, for an in-classroom-based IB program.
And as we know, online and remote instruction
significantly changes the way an education program
is delivered and received by students.
Violation of law, we stated earlier,
inadequate budget reserves.
And I stated all of this earlier,
but just to go over it again,
ECA is expected to maintain reserves
at 5% of expenditures, whichever is greater.
They've only been open this school year,
but out during that time,
they have not been able to meet this requirement.
A second issue, violation of law,
was their non-compliant independent study
written agreements.
Because they were an online program,
or have been, or continue to be for this school year,
they were required by law
to have independent study written agreements
with each of the students and families.
In our notice of violation,
we stated that ECA's independent study
written agreements were non-compliant.
They responded to this violation
by claiming that their independent study
written agreements are compliant,
and that the information was clearly
communicated to families.
We find that they have been out of compliance
for the majority of the 21-22 school year.
On February 25th, ECA did submit a draft
of a revised independent study master agreement,
showing that this violation has been partially cured.
However, ECA still has not submitted
revised independent study written agreements
for each of the students signed
as they're required to be by law to the CDE.
The last issue in the notice of violation
that we had pointed out was on December 1, 2021,
the El Dorado Charter,
Special Education Local Plan Area, SELPA,
issued a formal notice of its concerns
about ECA's ability to function as an LEA,
in that ECA at that time
had not set up a child fine process,
and the SELPA was concerned that students with disabilities
were not receiving their due services.
However, since that time,
the El Dorado Charter, SELPA,
has confirmed that ECA has resolved the issue
stated in the SELPA's letter of concern.
So in summary, the CDE,
the battery's running low here,
the CDE concludes that there is no fiscal viability
for ECA moving forward.
Based on our analysis,
the CDE estimates that ECA will have
an estimated negative ending cash balance of 488,353,
and a negative ending fund balance of 598,000 by June 2022.
ECA will fail to meet its financial obligations,
including, but not limited,
to staff salaries, pension obligations, and benefits
by May 2022,
and payments beginning in July 2022, if there were any,
would be offset to recover any remaining LCFF overpayment.
So in conclusion, there is substantial evidence
that ECA has committed the following,
fiscal mismanagement,
violation of several conditions, standards,
or procedures set forth in the charter,
violation of provisions of law.
ECA has not adequately refuted,
remedied, or proposed a plan
to remedy the aforementioned violations.
We are recommending that the State Board of Education
issue a notice of intent to revoke,
and notice of facts to ECA,
pursuant to Ed Code section 47607H.
At its February 15th meeting,
the ACCA has concurred with the CDE's recommendation,
and unanimously voted to recommend the same.
The CDE has contacted the districts of residence
for ECA's current students.
All districts have confirmed in writing
that they are prepared to provide
appropriate educational placement
of any student who resides within their district boundaries,
and we also,
and I'm sure you'll hear from them later,
we also have that confirmation
from the LA County Office of Education.
And that concludes my presentation.
I'm on mute.
Thank you very much.
At this point, we want to be able to hear
from Dr. Ogo Okoye-Johnson,
who is the CEO of Eagle Collegiate Academy.
And Dr. Okoye-Johnson, please begin.
You have about 10 minutes.
Then we will take public comments after that.
Okay.
Dr. Okoye-Johnson?
ECA is waiting for my slide to be uploaded.
Thank you.
By CDE, SBE, I submitted it to them,
so once they start, I would start.
Okay, thank you.
All right.
I think I can pull them up.
Is that a P-H-S-D-E?
I can see it in the folder.
It looks like it's in a corrupted file.
Dr. Okoye-Johnson, are you able to share from yours?
The staff was not informed
that we were to present from here,
and so we've been expecting you to be sharing
from your side, which you can do
through your Zoom function.
Yes, I could, but in the meeting that we had,
I was told that if I submitted, then they would share it,
but it's okay, I would have to pull it up.
I was ready for that to be done by staff, so.
We have a copy here we can open,
if that's what you'd prefer?
Well, that's what I thought we were doing,
because that's why I sent it in, but I also have it.
If you do it, then we're all on the same page.
It looks like it's about to happen, so.
Okay, we can open it.
Thank you, ma'am.
Thank you.
All right, I think we have the slide.
And Dr. Osorio, yes, go right ahead, please begin.
Thank you, ma'am.
Good afternoon, honorable Madam Board President
Dr. Darlene Harmon, honorable board members, and CDE staff.
My name is Dr. Ogokoye Johnson.
I am the founder and the chief of staff
of the Board of Trustees of the University of Michigan.
I am the president of the Board of Trustees
of the University of Michigan.
I am the founder and the chief executive officer
of Eagle Collegiate Academy, thanks to you.
With me today, our legal expert, Ms. Rooley,
and our fiscal expert, Mr. Adams.
We are a K through eight public charter school,
currently serving grades K through third,
and are the first and only international baccalaureate
primary years program candidate school,
serving the Antelope Valley
and the Santa Clarita Valley communities.
On behalf of our entire ECA community,
thank you for taking the time to hear us today.
We are asking the State Board of Education, next slide,
to delay action on a final decision
to revoke the ECA charter.
Such a delay is well within SBA's discretion,
and it's consistent with its regulations on this topic.
We are asking for the following reasons.
To minimize the devastation and the disruption
of the lives of the students and their families
that will come with immediate school closure.
To give ECA students time to use the facility
that has been set up for them for in-person instruction,
which has been so long promised,
and which Caltrans has cleared and notified CDE via email
that is clear to use.
ECA has sufficient financial resources
to finish out the school year,
despite the CDE's assertion to the contrary.
ECA will have the opportunity to receive
its already approved public charter school grant program
if we do get in person of $300,000,
as long as we meet the program's enrollment threshold,
which we believe we would need.
To avoid losing ECA's hard fought for IB candidacy,
to use the already paid for year-long instructional
and intervention materials have been purchased
that the students are using,
and all our current families have re-enrolled
for next school year,
and new families have also enrolled of 92.
Not only did the current families re-enroll
their current students,
they enroll some of their siblings as well.
We are conducting a robust enrollment campaign,
which includes email campaign, social media campaign,
we've been doing this door-to-door campaign,
and follow-up phone calls with families.
Some families have taught the facility,
and this is why we know that we have this enrollment.
Next slide.
As some of you know and remember,
the State Board unanimously approved ECA's petition
with conditions July 8th, with a one-year delayed opening.
And because of the pandemic, this is why that happened.
Our families and team were overjoyed at that prospect
after fighting for four years
to bring this excellent program to our communities.
There was no way for anyone to predict
that we will still be battling with the pandemic today.
California was under the lockdown stay-at-home order
from March 19, 2020,
and never really fully opened until June 2021.
ECA is caught in an impossible spiral.
We cannot enroll more students
until CDE approves our facility.
ECA cannot repay its debt to the CDE
until it can open our facility and enroll more students
and get some of the funding that we have.
So we are here today asking for a life raft
to pull us out of this spiral.
We ask for the sake of our Scholar Eagles,
that's what we call our students,
of our families and of our community
to delay the final action on this revocation
of ECA's hard fought charter.
Next slide.
We recognize the weightiness
of this heartbreaking situation for the SBE,
heartbreaking for the CDE
and for our whole ECA community, it's heartbreaking.
We appreciate all the work
that CDE has done these two years
to help us get started and running.
But we have been shocked lately
by their complete change in tone as of December.
We have been upfront with the CDE
since its charter was approved
and there is no evidence of any intent
by the ECA team, anyone,
to provide CDE any incorrect information
which CDE has alleged.
On May 28th, 2021, we notified CDE
that our facility was not ready at that time.
So they knew and we shared that information
in a written document that was submitted to you.
In December, ECA received a phone call
from the director of the CDE charter schools division.
The director has never called.
And so she explained that the CDE's intent
is to prepare the SBE to revoke ECA's charter.
And the director promised to send a link
to a previous SBE charter revocation
because she was not there at that time
so that we can see it and see what we would have
to go through and make a decision.
But we never received that link.
The director has fast-tracked this revocation process
and has dismissed the genuine remedies
and refutations that ECA has presented.
We have told them, whatever you need us to do,
we will do it, please tell us.
And we have been distressed over the lack of consistency
in communications from the CDE.
For example, the CDE's facility
and charter schools division staff told us verbally
that the youth ministry would work.
But then when we got the facility report,
it said that it would not work.
And then when they came in December,
they indicated that the site was not near
any airport runways,
but then the February report states that it is.
It feels as if though the goalposts
are constantly being moved down the field.
But thankfully Caltrans has notified CDE via email
that the current church site has been cleared by Caltrans.
It is now up to CDE to approve the site to be used.
In July, next slide.
In July, 2020, you gave us a chance to fulfill our calling
and we stand before you or sit before you today,
saying that we have done so.
Maybe not with the number of students
that we had wanted to,
but all our families are happy
and have re-enrolled for next school year
in addition to new families.
ECA students are thriving and showing growth
based on teacher and NWEA map growth test,
thereby meeting the learning outcomes of our charter.
And we were in communication with IB
throughout this process.
Our team is confident it will increase its enrollment
once it's allowed to start in-person instruction
because we know our families, we know where they are,
we have gone door to door to them
and we put those systems in place to do so.
Please allow us to fulfill what you allowed us to start.
There is a great need for ECA in our communities
and we can show that based on our enrollment campaign
that we have been conducting.
Revoking the ECA charter will only continue perpetuating
the cycle of struggling communities being silenced,
ignored instead of supported and void.
We still have five years of our charter term left.
We are literally new.
Please allow us to prove that we can implement
this educational program
despite the challenges of the pandemic.
Next slide.
The budget we submitted for this meeting
projected an idea of 13.51 by the P2 attendance report,
which is what we're using,
even though we know that we,
in order to receive the public charter school grant,
we can get more students before the end of the year,
which is June 30, 2022.
However, because of the fundraising campaign
we've been doing, we have received pledges
which we have submitted to SBEN CDE of $530,000 so far,
and we are still expecting more
from our capital fundraising campaign.
People are still, just the idea of trying to close the school
is heartbreaking that people are just coming out
and donating and pledging to ECEA.
And we also have 92 application forms
which we shared in our report.
So we know that our projection of 168 students
for next year is realistic.
We have people calling as they receive our email
and other campaigns.
Next slide.
We have pledges of up to $530,000 like I just mentioned,
which will help us to repay the LCFF,
but they will also repay the fund balance
that has been mentioned earlier.
If ECEA is allowed to continue to operate,
because that's then how we can pay CDE back
and also make sure that we meet that fund balance.
Next slide.
ECEA was in regular communication with the CDE
during the summer and early fall of 2021
based on information that we submitted to you in our report.
Again, Caltrans has cleared this site to use.
It's now up to CDE to sign off.
And we requested how they would like us
to notify them of all the other things
that we have already cleared from their February report.
And to date, we have not received information
as to how to do that.
We do reach out to CDE.
We ask for information to help us meet their requirements.
Dr. Akoya-Johnson.
Next slide.
Because ECEA could not operate in its present facilities.
Pardon me, ma'am.
The 10 minutes has just come to a close.
If you'd like to make a concluding statement.
She's a guy over there.
And so once again, we ask that the SBE
delay final action on the revocation of ECEA's charter
in order to allow sufficient time
for the facility to be up and running.
There is no legal or procedural need
to fast track revocation.
And it will only harm students
by removing them from their school home
during the middle of the year.
We have repeatedly cleared alleged violations
reached out to CDE,
including about independent study agreements
and everything else.
And we'll like to show you this current slide.
Thank you, ma'am.
Where you would see where we are.
Next slide.
Can we show the state board the slide
of this current place where they, so they can see it.
Dr. Akoya-Johnson, I apologize.
The time has come to a close.
Thank you for your comments.
All right.
Thank you so much for your time and for hearing us.
I'm sorry I was muted.
We want to put up the public comment slide
so that people can queue up for public comment.
Members of the public who want to provide comment
on this item can do so by calling the telephone number
and using the access code provided on the slide
that is shown now.
And while we're waiting for members of the public
to queue up, I want to just ask Vice President Glover-Woods
if she has any initial comments as state board liaison,
and then we will go to public comment.
President Darling-Hammond, thank you so much
for the opportunity to share.
I just want to concur and underscore
that the fiscal concerns that have been shared
in the presentation from the CDE staff
are of primary concern.
The fiscal insolvency that has been outlined
is again, something that is of great concern,
the fact that they are slated to run out of funds
before the school year does come to a close.
And I would like to also underscore
that the Advisory Commission on Charter Schools
discussed this revocation and heard some very similar
comments during their meeting in February.
And for our new board members just to know
that the ACCS is a board that is comprised
of multiple educational partners, if you will,
charter school operators, parents, teachers,
county superintendents, district superintendents,
and governing board members.
So it's a diverse body that takes care to listen
to the issues brought before them
before giving recommendations to this body
of the State Board of Education.
So the ACCS did unanimously recommend
that the State Board of Education issue a notice
of intent to revoke two EGLE collegiate academy.
They also were very concerned about the fiscal solvency
and I'd like to move forward President Darling-Hammond
when you do appropriate for public comment at this time
and the conversation and discussion
amongst the board members.
Thank you.
Thank you, we'll move to public comment.
Are there any public commenters?
Yes, there are currently 17 callers in the queue.
I will open up the phone line now.
Good afternoon, State Board of Education.
Please state your name and affiliation for the record.
Your time starts now.
You have one minute.
Hi, good afternoon.
My name is Dawn Hakeem and I have been involved
with EGLE collegiate academy since the very beginning.
I am urging you to please reconsider and work with us.
We are working very hard to drive fundraising and enrollment
and we really believe strongly
that our academic program is doing so well
and our families are so happy with it.
So we just need a little bit of help.
If we can just get a facility
and if we could have help with that,
then everything else will really fall into place
and we feel like we've been going back and forth
and we're really at a point where we have the site ready.
It can be our launching ground
and then we will be able to repay back these funds.
Schools are busy.
Thank you, call your time is up.
Thank you, caller.
Next caller, please state your name
and affiliation for the record.
You have one minute, your time starts now.
Good afternoon, my name is Michael Juba
and I'm a classroom teacher
representing the California Teachers Association.
CTA supports the CDE's recommendation
that the state board issue a notice of intent to revoke
with notice of facts to the EGLE collegiate academy.
The issues with ECA outlined by the CDE in the item
are egregious and CTA would like to highlight
that the consistent pattern of shifting enrollment numbers
led to the ECA being overfunded by almost $500,000
in public funds.
Perhaps the most troubling shift occurred
with ECA reporting to the CDE on September 30th
that they started school with 131 students
and then their attendance report only had 12.
ECA's actions are reminiscent of the A3 scandal
and we believe it would be prudent for the CDE
to investigate ECA's actions
to determine if this was gross management,
gross incompetence, or fraud.
Thank you, color.
Your time is up.
Next color, please state your name
and affiliation for the record.
Your time starts now.
You have one minute.
Hi, I'm calling because I would like you to support ECA.
I'm a mother of second grade,
I'm a mother of second grade student
and he's so happy over there
and I would like you to give him a chance,
to give them a chance.
And when my son is here, he wants to say something.
I love my school, please support it.
Thank you.
Thank you very much.
Next color, please state your name
and affiliation for the record.
You have one minute.
Your time starts now.
Good afternoon, board members.
My name is Andrew Ciccarelli
and I am the director of the charter school's office
for the Los Angeles County Office of Education.
Back on July 8th of 2020,
we presented to this board
with the county and district's concerns
with the Eagle Collegiate Academy charter petition.
We found the petitioners demonstrably unlikely
to successfully implement the petition
and in particular,
we noted the petitioner's unrealistic enrollment plan
and an underestimation of the cost and time it would take
to bring an identified and wholly unfit facility
into compliance.
Despite an extra planning year
and the petitioner's strong assurances to the contrary,
these dilemmas have indeed come to pass
to the detriment of their students and community.
The school has enrolled only 12 students
inadequately adjusting their budgets
and has been unable to secure an appropriate facility,
providing a remote educational program
that is deficient and in violation of law.
Your staff have provided a detailed and compelling report,
the Eagle Collegiate Academy is not a good option
for its community and it is in the best interest
of this community for the school to close.
The district and county are prepared to help.
Thank you, caller.
Your time is up.
In addition to other more productive educational options,
I urge you to revoke this school.
Thank you.
Next caller, please state your name
and affiliation for the record.
You have one minute.
Your time starts now.
It can't be too loud.
Good afternoon, caller.
Please state your name and affiliation for the record.
Your time starts now.
Caller.
Oh, hi, my name.
Go ahead.
Hello.
My name is Ashley Cousteau.
I am a teacher at Eagle Collegiate Academy
and a second and third grade teacher.
And this school means so much
to the staff and the faculty and the students
and the parents and we have done so much
to try to meet your needs
and to be able to keep these students going
and they are dreading the idea
of their school closing down.
Their grades are phenomenal
with how much time that they are given in class
with not as many students
but given the best instruction possible
and they just wanna finish off this school year
and continue at their school.
If you could please help us, work with us
because these students would be so devastated.
Thank you, caller.
Time is up.
Next caller, please state your name
and affiliation for the record.
You have one minute.
Your time starts now.
Caller, please state your name
and affiliation for the record.
Your time starts now.
Okay, moving on.
Next caller.
Please state your name and affiliation.
Your time starts now.
Hello, my name is Jack Ritter
and I'm a community member at Inalga Duce
and I just hope that you guys please let ECA continue.
I think it is important for these students
to have consistency at this young age
and be at the same facility with the same teachers.
I think change may be detrimental to their development
at the stage of their lives.
The teachers at ECA have done a great job
educating the students
and the improvement is evident
in the facts in the school.
The relationships built between the teachers
and the students are very important
for these students' lives
and I just hope that you please think about the students' lives
when making these decisions.
Thank you.
Next caller, please state your name
and affiliation for the record.
Your time starts now.
You have one minute.
Hi, my name is Paulina
and I'm calling in support of Eagle Crooked Academy.
ECA is providing value to students
and I'm asking you not to close the school.
Thank you.
Next caller, please state your name
and affiliation for the record.
Your time starts now.
You have one minute.
Hello, my name is Rita Solaya.
I'm the ECA board of the director member
and I'm calling for supporting
and asking please do not disturb our children's lives
by closing the school where they are thriving,
learning and growing every day.
Closing ECA before the school has the opportunity
to serve all the families that want to attend
and perpetuate why the rich keeps getting richer
and the poor keeps getting poorer
because you would be taking away the opportunity
for our children to change their future
by assessing the quality of education
for ECA they need and deserve.
Please do not close with this beginning of time
and every time we come into a halt,
it's affecting our children.
I'm a mother of four children
which essentially lost the opportunity
to attend to this, to ECA due to the fact
that we have been going back and forth
and being able to open ECA on time.
Thank you.
Thank you, caller.
Next caller, please state your name
and affiliation for the record.
You have one minute.
Your time starts now.
Hello.
Go ahead, caller.
Thank you.
My name is Eliana Howe
and I'm one of the special ed teachers at the school
that has been supporting ECA for many years
and I just would like to have the school continue
helping the students in the community.
Thank you.
Thank you very much.
Next caller, please state your name
and affiliation for the record.
You have one minute.
Your time starts now.
Hi, my name is Ruth Posey.
I'm a parent in the community.
I would like to say that I support the school,
the teachers, the staff, and the families, most importantly.
I think the school is very good for the community
because of the excellent instructional program
and care for the students and family
and I think it would be unfair to interrupt the instruction
for the students, the children,
and the families who are gone this far into the school year
and who are really thriving and learning.
With the connection to classmates and the teachers,
it seems like it's a very great program
and I wish you would give it another chance to stay open.
Thank you.
Next caller, please state your name
and affiliation for the record.
You have one minute.
Your time starts now.
Caller, with the number ending in one six.
I would just like to say that I support.
Okay, thank you very much.
Yeah, and I think that it should be given the chance
to finish out the school year.
Thank you, caller.
Next caller, please state your name
and affiliation for the record.
Your time starts now.
You have one minute.
Hello, good afternoon.
My name is Uzo Madusky.
I'm just pleading that you consider leaving ECA to thrive.
Please do not close down the school.
Thank you.
Next caller, please state your name
and affiliation for the record.
You have one minute.
Your time starts now.
Hi, I'm in support of Eagle Collegiate Academy continuing.
I have two children that will be attending
Eagle Collegiate Academy in the fall.
And I'm looking forward to being able to make that choice
to which school I want to send my children.
So I just ask that you would continue to help ECA
and support ECA and keep the school open.
Thank you.
Next caller, please state your name
and affiliation for the record.
Your time starts now.
You have one minute.
Hi, my name is Jolie.
I have two kids in ECA and I'm here to support the school.
I would like you guys to give us the opportunity to stay open.
My kids are so happy with this school.
The teachers are so great.
The directors, everybody, we are so happy.
And we ask you guys to leave that school open.
It's gonna be a great impact, not just for Santa Clarita,
but for the areas I would do say.
And I know it's gonna be great.
We're gonna do amazing if you guys give us a chance
to stay open.
My kids, they have been learning so much.
They have been developing themselves so much.
And I'm so happy with this school.
Please give us the opportunity to stay open.
And I know you guys not gonna,
you're gonna be happy with this school.
Thank you.
Next caller, please state your name
and affiliation for the record.
You have one minute.
Your time starts now.
Hello.
Hi.
My name is Ezekiel Morikori.
I am a father of two.
I will freedom not to close the ETA class at school
because my kids are doing better.
Hey guys, say something, don't close your school.
Please not, don't close our school.
We really need it.
Our class is the best at the ETA class.
Don't close our school, we don't need it.
Because if we don't have it,
we won't be able to do school or learn.
Are you finished with your public comment?
Is there?
Please close the school.
Thank you so much.
Thank you very much.
Next caller, please state your name
and affiliation for the record.
You have one minute.
Your time starts now.
This is Elizabeth Chislett
and I'm calling as a community member.
Our community really needs a school
like Eagle Collegiate Academy.
The students are very happy learning there
and they would be devastated if the school closes.
Please allow the school to remain open
so their education is not disrupted.
Thank you.
Next caller, please state your name
and affiliation for the record.
Your time starts now.
Caller, are you?
Hi, my name is Isabella
and I'm a potential parent at Eagle Collegiate Academy.
I see the value that Eagle Collegiate Academy has
through its educators, its teachers, its staff,
and I am very happy to be a part of it.
And I am so excited for my children
to be a part of their instructional programs
such as their international baccalaureate
and primary years program candidacy.
I believe in a strong mission
and I do not want the school to be closed down
for my children not to have the experience
that the current students are having.
Our staff, the teachers are so wonderful
from what I've heard and seen.
And it's just, we really want the school to stay open
so that our children and more children can experience
what our children are experiencing now.
Thank you.
Next caller, please state your name
and affiliation for the record.
You have one minute.
Your time starts now.
Hi, my name is Christine.
And I support EPA.
Go ahead, caller.
The school has a great education program
and it is good for the community,
especially for the students.
It would be bad and such a shame to close the school down,
especially in the middle of the school year.
Please do not shut down Eagle Collegiate Academy.
Thank you.
Next caller, please state your name
and affiliation for the record.
You have one minute.
Your time starts now.
Thank you.
Hi, my name is Mobology.
I am a parent of a third grader at ECA
and I have two potential children coming in in the fall.
Please help us keep ECA open
for the betterment of this young kid
and also to avoid disruption of the educational learning
that is already going.
My daughter is very happy with her teacher
and she has already made a strong bond with her classmates.
ECA, from what I've observed,
has come with total hard work, rigorous curriculum
and great determination to make sure
that the students succeed.
Please help us keep the school open.
Thank you.
Next caller, please state your name
and affiliation for the record.
You have one minute.
Your time starts now.
Hi, my name is Anna Morales.
I'm a parent of a third grader, my son Andrew,
and I'm in support of Eagle Collegiate Academy
to stay open.
My son comes from a background of homeschooling.
It took me a long time to find a good fit for my son
and in Eagle Collegiate Academy,
he has been just learning, being successful.
He has grown in many ways.
I'm very excited and happy for him to continue on.
So please, please keep this school open
because it will be a detriment to my son
and here's my son, Andrew.
Thank you.
I apologize.
I think I...
My name is Andrew and I really like this school.
My teacher, Ms. Crustel, and my classmates,
they bring really good education
and I'm involved with the fun too.
My name's Andrew.
Thank you.
Thank you, Andrew.
Next caller, please state your name
and affiliation for the record.
You have one minute.
Your time starts now.
Hi, my name is Oge and I'm a parent.
I would like to appeal to you to keep ECA open.
It has an excellent, excellent program for the students
and the teachers, everybody, the kids are so happy
to be there, the parents are happy
and they are giving them excellent education.
The program is wonderful.
It will be a tragedy if you close this school.
Keep it open and see what they can do.
Give them the opportunity to show you
that it's an excellent, excellent, for emphasis, I repeat,
excellent, excellent program that they have.
So keep it open.
You can hear everybody.
It is imperative that you keep it open.
I appeal to you to do that.
Thank you.
Next caller, please state your name
and affiliation for the record.
You have one minute.
Your time starts now.
Good afternoon, caller.
Are you there?
You are live.
Please start your public comment.
I'm sorry, I did already.
That's okay.
Go ahead.
Oh, you already made a public comment?
Yes.
Okay, thank you very much.
Next caller, please state your name
and affiliation for the record.
You have one minute.
Your time starts now.
Hello, my name is Uche Madishke.
I happen to be one of the parents
of the students that goes to ECA.
I want to passionately plea
that you leave this school open.
My daughters have been having a wonderful,
one-of-a-kind experience going in there.
Come back every time and they tell me
how they have been taught different languages,
South Korean and all of that.
So the opportunity for them to be multilingual
actually exists by them going to this school.
So I'll plead with you
that you please leave this school open.
Thank you.
Next caller, please state your name
and affiliation for the record.
You have one minute.
Your time starts now.
Caller with the number ending in two,
I'm sorry, 4048.
Please start your public comment now.
Well, I just,
I just believe in my comment.
Okay, sorry.
Thank you very much, sir.
Next caller, please state your name
and affiliation for the record.
You have one minute.
Your time starts now.
Hello, my name is Jenny,
and I love this school and my teacher.
And I hope you
open this school so I can go to school.
The next caller, please state your name
and affiliation for the record.
You have one minute.
Your time starts now.
And it looks like that concludes public comment
for item number five.
Thanks to all of the people who commented.
We appreciate you showing up and giving us your input.
And now we need to find out
if we have some more discussion on the board.
Any questions?
Yes, member Bonanca.
So I have a clarifying question.
It seems like many of the issues stem
from the difference between the predicted enrollment
and the actual enrollment.
And so I'm just curious,
how was ECA able to predict the enrollment of 131 students
and was that prediction corroborated by any evidence
or was it checked by any state agency
before it was approved?
So maybe we wanna go first to Stephanie McFarland
on your second part of your question
and then we can go to Dr. Akoya Johnson.
So I might bring in our fiscal services division.
I know Kiyomi Meeker is on the line
to help answer any fiscal questions,
but yes, the way that new and expanding charters are funded
is that they estimate how many students
that they are going to receive.
So they estimated 168 students, I believe,
on their PENSEC report
and that is what they were funded for.
A 20-day report comes out
and we received that the beginning of November,
I think November 1st, which indicated they had 12.
So there is a little bit of a time-lapse
between finding how much they were funded
and how many they actually had.
So there is, that's sort of the verification
is that 20-day report of how many students they have.
And I'm sure Kiyomi, if you're on the line,
you could probably answer that more elegantly than I could.
But if you feel like-
We see Kiyomi.
You did a good job, Stephanie.
And just for background for the board members,
hi, Kiyomi Meeker, education fiscal administrator
in the school fiscal services division.
This is how we fund all new charters
because the advance funding is based
for all LEAs on prior year ADA
and new charters don't have that.
We have something called the special advance
and so the first one is an estimate.
They do their best guess based on enrollment
and then the first time we get real data
or based on actual numbers is the 20-day.
And so that's where we saw the discrepancy.
If that answers your question,
are there any other questions or comments?
Yes, member Cleverwoods.
First, I'd like to thank all of the students
and the parents and the staff members
from Equal Collegiate Academy that called in.
It's just quite unfortunate that we are even at a place
to have this discussion this afternoon.
It's such a challenge to open a new school
and opening a new school in the midst of a pandemic
makes it even more challenging.
With that being said, this grave concern that I have
is regarding the fiscal insolvency.
The numbers that have been shared based on CDE's projections
and even Equal Collegiate Academy's projections
just show that there is a gross fiscal insolvency
for the school and the ability for them
to continue to operate with such a deficit
is, it makes it very challenging to do so at a minimum.
So I, again, just want to say to the communities
and to my fellow board members,
this is a challenging and difficult decision to be made.
And I will be ready to make a motion
when it is time to do so.
Are there any other questions
or comments from board members?
Seeing none, I think we are ready for a motion,
Vice President Cleverwood.
Thank you, President Burley-Hammond.
I move that we,
I move that we issue a notice of intent
to revoke with notice of facts
pursuant to Education Code Section 47607H at this time.
Is there a second?
Second that.
Thank you, any further discussion?
Hearing none, Brooks, can you please call the roll call vote?
Member Rodriguez.
Yes.
Member Patilio-Brownson.
Member McQuillan.
Yes.
Member Orozco-Gonzalez.
Member Olken.
Member Lewis.
Yes.
Vice President Cleverwood.
Member Escobedo.
Yes.
President Darlin-Hammond.
Member Bonacca.
Aye.
The motion carries.
Thank you, I want to thank Dr. Ogoda-Koya-Johnson
for her work on this charter
and the work of staff who called in and the students.
We feel the pain that you experienced.
We also want to thank Stephanie Farland
and the members of our CDE staff
who have been doing extensive due diligence
on this question for quite some time
and we appreciate their efforts very much.
And with that, we're going to take a 10-minute break.
I'd like to ask board members
to please just turn off your microphones and cameras
and do not leave the meeting.
And we will see you at 2.55, we'll give you 11 minutes.
Thank you.
All right, welcome back.
Board members, we need to reestablish a quorum,
so Brooks is going to call the roll.
Member Rodriguez.
Present.
Member Petillo-Brownson.
Member McQuillan.
Here.
Member Orozco-Gonzalez.
Member Olken.
Member Lewis.
Present.
Vice President Cleverwood.
Here.
Member Escobedo.
Present, Darlene Hammond.
Here.
Member Bonacca.
Member Quorum.
Excellent, thank you.
We're moving to item six.
Item six is the approval of modifications
to California's 2020 to 2023
Unified Strategic Workforce Development Plan.
And the CDE recommends that we approve
the modified state plan under the Workforce Innovation
and Opportunity Act of 2014.
This item will be presented by Tim Rainey,
Executive Director of the California
Workforce Development Board,
and Carolyn Zachary, the Administrator
of the Adult Education Office of the State Department,
with an introduction by Pete Callis,
who is Director of the College and Career Division
of the CDE.
Pete, Tim, and Carolyn, please begin.
Good afternoon, President Darlene Hammond,
state board members, Superintendent Thurmond,
and Chief Deputy Nicely.
I'm Pete Callis, the Division Director
over the Career and College Transition Division.
My team, small but mighty, Tim Rainey,
and Carolyn Zachary are here to present on this item.
I'd like to introduce Carolyn Zachary,
our Administrator over the Adult Education Office,
and Tim Rainey, the Executive Director
of the California Workforce Development Board
to take you through our item.
Thank you.
All right, I'm going to start sharing my screen first.
I'm hoping you can all see that, and here we go.
All right, well, good afternoon, Superintendent Thurmond,
President Darlene Hammond, and Vice President Clover Woods.
We will be presenting information
and seeking approval today
for the Workforce Innovation and Opportunity Act
state plan modifications.
The acronym for the Workforce Innovation
and Opportunity Act is WIOA.
As background, the first California state plan
was approved by the state board in January 2016
with mid-plan modifications approved in 2018.
The current state plan was approved by the state board
in 2020, and today we are bringing forward
the mid-plan modifications.
Tim Rainey, the Executive Director
of the California Workforce Development Board
will provide information on the state plan.
I will follow with information about our adult education,
Title II Adult Education and Family Literacy Act section.
Tim?
Thank you, Carolyn.
Honored to be here, President Hammond, thank you very much.
And I also want to thank Superintendent Thurmond
for being a member of the State Workforce Development Board
and Pete Callis for participating so much
in the state board's work,
and my friend and colleague Patricia Dacasse is on,
and of course, my good friend and colleague,
Carolyn Zachary, for all your support and work with us.
Great partnership, us and y'all.
I'll go through some basic background, if I could,
and I should apologize in advance.
I know you've been at it all day,
and here I am, another talking head,
so I don't bore you to tears.
I don't have any presentation material,
so that's on me, sorry about that.
So I'll just talk for a bit,
and I'll hand it back to Carolyn to talk about the CD part.
Quickly on the background,
the Workforce Innovation Opportunities
and the Workforce Development Board,
the Workforce Innovation Opportunity Act,
as Carolyn said, requires that every four years,
the State Workforce Development Board,
every state has to do this with its WIOA title partners.
We have to publish a unified
strategic workforce development plan,
AKA what we call the state plan.
We also do a mandatory modification every two years,
and that's in fact what this is, it's a modification.
And then next year, we're gonna dive into
with your help and partnership
in developing a brand new state strategic plan.
So what I'm talking about now is the modification.
The federally approved plan
has to include all of those WIOA titles.
Title one, adult dislocated worker and youth funding,
that as you know is administered
through 45 local workforce boards
around the state of California.
Title two, that you're more than aware of.
Title three, Wagner-Pizer Employment Service Program
that's administered through
the Employment Development Department.
And then finally, title four,
that's Vocational Rehabilitation
that's administered
through the Department of Rehabilitation.
So as our current,
I think Carolyn might have already said this,
but our current plan is gonna run to July, 2023.
And at that point, we'll start the process
of rewriting a new state plan.
The plan modification that we're talking about today
has to be to the US Department of Labor by March 15th.
So I really deeply appreciate the recommendation
to approve this draft.
We just got it back from 30 days of public comment.
We've incorporated all of that comment
and we're pretty close to ready to finalize
and do that submittal.
The drafts, the modification is unfortunately
not unlike what I presented to you before.
So I guess again, I'm apologizing for going over
some of the same grounds.
If you're like me though, you forgot what I said.
So it's gonna be all new
and you'll validate everything my kids say to me,
which will be good.
The state plan is built on three policy objectives
and on seven strategies.
There's also a vision that is the underpinning
of the state plan that we call High Road.
And I wanna come back to that right at the end.
The three state plan objectives, the policy objectives
are fostering demand-driven skills attainment.
And that means aligning workforce and education programs
with industry sectors so that employers
have the skilled workers they need.
And secondly, enabling upward mobility for all Californians.
And that means making workforce and education programs
easily accessible and navigable,
especially for workers with barriers to employment
and prioritizing investments in skills
that lead to quality jobs and economic security.
And then finally, the last policy objective,
aligning, coordinating and integrating programs
and services across systems
so that we economize our limited resources
for scale and impact.
And using this unified plan, the state plan
is a very important way of getting at that.
The seven state plan strategies, and I'll be very quick,
sector strategies is number one.
We really emphasize this because this is a way
to connect programs around the state
to pathways into good jobs
that are driving regional employment.
That's really important to the overall vision
and strategy of the state plan.
Career pathways is the second.
Regional partnerships, we always say
that programs should be delivered locally,
closest to the communities and people who most need support.
But industry sectors don't organize
within political jurisdictions or school jurisdictions.
They organize regionally, so we need to tie into sectors,
again, that are driving regional employment
and that offer the best jobs and careers.
That work benefits both the industries
that we're trying to help be more competitive,
but also the communities that we aim to impact.
The fourth one is earn and learn.
Combining quality applied learning with compensation
is kind of the general definition of that.
But as you know, the governor has really prioritized
formalized apprenticeship in California,
not just in the construction trades,
but in industry sectors beyond the trades.
And there's a great deal of work going on around that.
Supportive services is the fifth.
People can't afford the time to pursue
quality skills training without supports.
Child care, transportation, counseling, mentoring,
housing, income supports are all very important
to make that possible.
The next one, number six,
is creating cross-system data capacity,
such as our current partnership with CDE on our CalSkills,
which is using cross-system performance data
to assess the value of different interventions,
workforce interventions.
We just did an impact analysis of this incredible data
with the California Policy Lab
that we would love to come back and share with you.
And then finally, integrated service delivery.
So through this coordination, data system alignment,
co-enrollment, making a complex patchwork
of local programs much more navigable, as I said before,
for both workers and employers.
We did spend a lot of time last year
working with your staff,
reaffirming areas of focus
that went into this modification of our state plan.
One is around integrated service delivery
and leveraging supportive services.
Using co-enrollment among the WIOA titles
is a big part of that.
Also, a common intake process
and aligned data collection and analysis,
that's especially critical for program and system alignment.
And again, getting to that navigability of the system
so it's not such a patchwork and difficult for people
who don't have time to be messing around
with a siloed system of workforce and economic services
and in education services.
And we'll be participating in the technical assistance.
It's actually a work group for co-enrollment
that we're engaged in with California
Department of Education, CDE.
Providing technical assistance to the field
is a big piece of that.
Also, educating local partners on the value
and available resources of the Education Options Office,
critical resources and support.
And then finally, for Perkins,
recommitting to greater regional coordination
in integrated service delivery.
So utilizing the local and regional planning efforts,
for example, among workforce boards,
strong workforce program in Perkins Five
to achieve that deeper system alignment.
And we will be supporting the state plan
for career and technical education efforts
under the California Workforce Pathways
Joint Advisory Committee.
That is the plan in a nutshell.
And if I could, I'd like to go back to the vision
that's underpinning all of this work
because I think it's important.
Over the last couple of years,
it's where we've really kind of refined our approach
to workforce development and how we get
to that kind of system change
that could impact equity in the state.
This is, I think, the California Workforce Development Boards
and the state plans and our partners,
real contribution to getting at the governor's vision
of a California for all.
I think, and I can say this
because I've been part of the workforce system
for a long time, too long.
Well, I shouldn't say too long.
We have a lot of work to do.
The traditional workforce approach is inadequate
on its own for addressing poverty and inequality
in California.
We keep trying to push people into labor markets
and hope they get jobs.
President Obama used to call that train of praise
one of my favorite lines
that I think it really sort of describes
the challenge that we have.
We can't just expect that people are gonna attach.
We have to make those connections happen.
We get a lot right as a workforce development system,
especially serving people that most need to leg up
in competitive labor markets.
But I think we get one important thing wrong.
Rather than responding to labor markets,
we need to be in the business of shaping labor markets.
Otherwise, we're not gonna move the needle
on economic equity.
A structural problem that we have to contend with
is that there aren't enough good jobs
for the number of people who need good jobs.
MIT economist, David Otter,
who recently came out with a wonderful book.
I wish I had the title in front of me.
I tell you, Google him.
He likens this challenge of too few good jobs
to a basketball game in a high school gym
where you've got a fixed number of seats
and you've got more spectators showing up for the game
than there are seats and everybody wants to sit down.
And the seats will go to those who are quick
and aggressive in sitting down.
And we can train people to be faster.
We can train people to be more aggressive
for the next game.
But the fact is,
you still have the same number of fixed seats.
So as a workforce system,
if we don't change the way we approach workforce development
from that traditional approach,
then we're gonna continue to feed this competition
for too few good jobs.
And who loses out in that competition
have been historically marginalized.
So to move the needle on economic equity
to get to that California for all,
we can't just respond to labor markets who said,
we have to be in the business of shaping them.
And to us, that means at least three things.
One is improving access to good jobs
built into the objectives that are described
in the state strategic plan.
Improving access to good jobs
means connecting existing workforce programs
to not just any jobs,
but the best jobs in industry sectors
with projected growth and openings.
So being very deliberate about
not just we'll respond to markets,
but we're looking at what the trends are
in terms of where the openings are over the next five years.
But we're also paying a lot of attention to job quality.
The second one is creating more good jobs.
So we could use our public dollars, the people's money,
to subsidize high road employers
and help them be more competitive and grow
rather than subsidizing the low road companies
that offer high turnover, low wage jobs,
and that are dangerous in many cases.
And the third one is improving existing jobs.
So we can, and we're doing this all over California
as a matter of fact,
working with employers that are interested in job quality
as a way to improve recruitment
and the retention of talent.
So I'll finish up with kind of hitting
the three high road principles
of equity, job quality, and climate.
So that's the approach that we're taking with high road
and applying it not just to workforce programs,
but also to policy in Sacramento.
Job quality is starting with quality jobs in sectors,
again, that are driving regional employment.
And a good job has been defined in many places,
but I think it's worth saying safe and just workplace,
living wages, family health benefits,
retirement and pension contributions if possible,
investment and training and job mobility,
worker voice and agency on the job
and fair and predictable scheduling are just a few
of those kinds of components that make up
a good quality job.
We can focus on those as a workforce system
and attaching the people that we wanna impact to those.
We can't achieve equity
if we don't pay attention to job quality.
And then equity is workforce programs
that I think are doing really good on this score
and focusing on populations
that have significant barriers to employment.
The trick is to make sure that we're not thinking
that any job is a good job and kind of erasing that
from the workforce culture and focusing
on the best quality jobs and making sure we're getting
people pathways to those jobs.
And then finally, climate, focusing on building resiliency
for industries and workers and communities
that are most impacted by climate.
Our end game is to increase economic equity
by transforming the way whole industry sectors
recruit, hire, promote and retain talent.
I think we can do that.
In fact, we are doing it.
So we end up with a California economy
that's defined by quality jobs.
It's defined by equity and defined by climate resilience.
So this is long game stuff.
I'll end there.
Thank you very much.
Thank you so much, Tim.
I always appreciate the hearing from you
and your enthusiasm.
I hope that I can mirror that enthusiasm
for our Title II programs that I'm going to share about now.
So I'd first like to, I'm going to jump through
a couple of slides because Tim talked about
the totality of the WIOA programs.
And those include Title I,
which is the dislocated worker adult,
dislocated worker adult program and youth program.
And he also talked about Title III, Wagner-Pyser
and Title IV, which is vocational rehabilitation program.
So he touched on those,
but I really want to dive deeper into adult education
and the Adult Education and Family Literacy Act,
which is Title II of WIOA.
And I first want to start with just one or two sentences
about the history of adult education in California.
We've been working for well over 150 years in California
to help adults move their families forward
on a solid economic path.
Back in 1856, the San Francisco Board of Education
opened night programs for immigrants
to help them learn English
and at that time, vocational skills.
And so we have a solid footing in California
in adult education and are probably one of the oldest states
to offer adult education from such a long time ago.
Title II, as you'll see, focuses on helping adults
become literate, whether it's in English
or just in general literacy
to become economically self-sufficient.
We also have the focus on family literacy
where we're helping parents improve their skills
to then also help their children
improve their skills in school.
That's the family literacy component.
We're also looking at how we can help adults
attain their secondary school diploma,
whether that's through a high school diploma program
or through an equivalency program such as GED or Hiset.
We have a large focus on our immigrant population
and as you'll see a little later,
our immigrants and our students
who speak a language other than English
make up the majority of the individuals that we serve.
In order to be served in adult education,
you have to be 18 years of age or older
and you do not need to have a social security number.
You don't have to have any right to work documentation.
This is a little different
than some of the other title programs
although we are working very hard as Tim has talked about
to ensure equity.
So we're striving to find as many services
with our title partners.
So we call title one, three and four
to ensure that everyone can receive services.
The students that come to us as Tim talked about
often have some barriers
and it could be that they have limited English,
limited education, they may be in a low income job
and wanna improve their skills
and maybe coming to us with some disabilities
or they may have some limited career skills
and they want to improve those career skills.
Tim also talked about co-enrollment
and we've been working on co-enrollment in California
for several years and feel that we're making great strides
in co-enrollment.
Co-enrollment is where students who are in adult education
are also being served
at our America's Job Centers for California
or they're being served
at the Department of Rehabilitation.
And the idea is that they can help improve
their English skills,
they can earn that diploma or their equivalency
and most importantly, we can help them to upskill
into better, to good jobs as we're calling them.
But we know that adults also in co-enrollment
can learn these new career skills
if they need to re-skill to move into a new career.
They want to enter or re-enter the workforce,
they again want to improve their reading or their math
and also a big focus of our adult education programs
is preparing students for citizenship.
We're going to provide an overview of funding
for adult education in California
because WIOA is not our only source.
We have programs that receive LCFF funding,
the Local Control Funding Formula.
If they're sitting in a community college
non-credit program, they're receiving apportionment
and many of our programs also,
especially our community-based faith-based organizations
receive donations and our library literacy programs
are supported by state library funds.
The bulk of the dollars though
that support adult education in California
come through the state from the adult education program
called CAPE and we receive over $560 million
in that fund source to support adult learning
throughout the state.
And then our WIOA Title II fund
is around 107 million this last year.
Where would you find adult programs?
Where are they located?
They're situated in K-12 schools or K-adult schools,
so associated with the school district.
They're in community college, non-credit programs,
community faith-based organizations, libraries.
We even have some workforce development boards
that are offering Title II programs
and corrections is another big area of focus.
These are the program areas
that you will find students learning in our programs,
adult basic and secondary education programs
for immigrants, including civics education,
citizenship and ESL, family literacy,
integrated education and training.
This is where we are increasing our partnerships
with our local workforce development boards
and the high road training programs
that in partnerships that Tim talked about,
workforce entry and re-entry,
adults with disabilities, pre-apprenticeships
and short-term career technical education.
Those three have asterisks
because those programs cannot be supported with WIOA funds
and they're only supported with our state funds.
Now COVID certainly had an impact
and that was part of the information
that was included in our state plan modifications
is how we reacted to COVID throughout the state.
But as you can see, we have seen declining enrollment.
I will say though that this year
when we compare the first six months
to last year's first six months,
we are seeing a great uptick in enrollment in our programs.
This slide just gives you a general overview
of enrollment across the various programs in the state.
There's a difference between students that are enrolled,
reportable individuals and participants.
And so when we're looking at our participants,
those are students that have been enrolled in our programs
for 12 or more hours of instruction
and have a pre-test and a post-test.
So they've been in the program long enough
and had enough hours to be pre and post-tested.
What do our students look like?
We have over 60% of our students are Hispanic or Latino,
16% Asian, 12 white and around 6% are African American.
Nearly 50% of our students are between the ages of 24,
25 and 44 and then our next largest demographic
really were kind of equal there
between the 19 and 24 year olds and the 45 and 54 year olds.
Right now what's happening in many of our programs
is we have all three types of instruction happening.
We have online instruction, in-person instruction,
as well as hybrid instruction.
And instruction happens in adult education all the time.
It can happen on a 24 hour cycle
with our online instruction.
And many of our programs found that they had increases
in students through the online programs,
logging on at 10 o'clock at night at one in the morning
because they were able to work that into their work schedule.
And that is truly a benefit of our programs.
So in closing, I would just like to ask
that the Board of Education approve the modifications
to our state plan and I'm happy to answer any questions.
Thank you so much, very inspiring.
We want to put the public comment slide up
so that people can queue up for public comment
by calling the number and dialing the access code listed there.
And before we go to public comment,
I would like to see if our liaisons,
member McQuillin and Rodriguez
would like to offer some comments.
Member McQuillin.
Just want to thank the staff for their great presentation.
It's such an important program
to helping some of our most vulnerable community members
who are trying to become more employable
and get literacy skills and, you know,
in some of our places that we really need
to help people out in those vulnerable places,
whether it be incarceration, our community centers
and libraries and other locations.
So such an important program.
So thank you for the presentation.
Member Rodriguez, I'd like to echo
my fellow members comments.
I think that both Mr. Tim Rainey and Carolyn Zachary
did a wonderful job of overviewing this particular,
giving all of the nuts and bolts.
And so as a liaison, I will stick with the impact.
I actually started in adult education.
I started my career in teaching
and in a community like mine, which is so impoverished
and we have so many recent immigrants.
I've noticed that adult education is a program
that helps people gain confidence.
Parents teach their children how to read.
Sorry about that little cough in the background.
My dog has a tracheal collapse.
But you know, there are so many opportunities,
adults who need diplomas to move up in their jobs,
moms learning English so that they can support
their families and then additionally,
which is another item that we'll see tomorrow,
but the CT opportunities for the adults
where they can venture down new career pathways.
And that's where watching the parents become empowered,
you know, it trickles into the family,
especially the adult literacy, right?
You know, when there's family literacy programs.
Thank you.
Very, very helpful.
Do we have any public comment?
We do, there is one caller in the queue.
I will open up the phone line now.
Good afternoon, caller.
Please state your name and affiliation for the record.
You have one minute.
Your time starts now.
Hi, this is Hayen Kimner
with the California Community Schools Learning Exchange.
We're thrilled to hear this update
that reflects your commitment to cultivating
and strengthening alignment and partnerships
in support of a holistic approach to equitable learning,
innovation and improvement and capacity building.
This particular use of the federal WIAO
to support family and adult literacy
is an important facet to an LEA's community school strategy,
if done intentionally, to integrate and align efforts,
communities, partners and staff.
Not only is this about engaging adults and families,
but connecting it to support K-12 literacy,
higher ed and workforce partners
and other municipal partners
is the work of community schools in action.
And these important community schools muscles of partnership
are integral to maximizing all of our state
and federal investments and transformation.
Thank you so much.
Thank you.
And that concludes public comment for item number six.
And that was a wonderful connecting of the dots
between our community schools initiatives
and many of the adult education initiatives
and workforce initiatives
that really do make a big difference in that context.
So I now wanna just ask the board members
if there's any discussion or questions
or comments on the item.
Yes, member McClellan.
So did I, just clarification going forward,
this is a modification at the two year junction
and then next year we'll be diving in further
to modify the plan or create a whole new plan.
Is that what I heard?
Thank you.
Yes.
Yes, that's correct.
Thank you.
Any other comments or questions?
All right, member McClellan, your hand is still up.
Is that another comment or are you ready to make a motion?
I'm ready to make the motion to adopt the plan
with the modifications as stated.
Do I have a second?
Second it.
Thank you very much.
And is there any further discussion?
All right, is there any further discussion?
I just wanted to appreciate the call out
on family literacy and the lifting up
of the two generation approach,
which I think is such an important through line
to all of our K to 12 schools,
but also just making sure that it is,
it hasn't always, I think, been lifted up
and I appreciate that you all are doing that.
Thank you.
Perfect, thank you.
All right, seeing no more discussion,
Brooks, please call the roll for the vote.
Member Rodriguez.
Yes.
Member Petillo-Brownson.
Member McClellan.
Yes.
Member Orozco-Gonzalez.
Member Olken.
Member Lewis.
Yes.
Vice President Glover-Woods.
Member Escobedo.
Yes.
President Darlin-Hammond.
Member Bonacca.
Aye.
Motion carries.
All right, terrific, thank you very much
for the presentation, as I said, very inspiring
and we can move on now to our last items,
which are the consent agenda.
And the regular consent items are items eight through 10.
We do want to open up the phone line again
for a public comment on those consent items.
Members of the public wishing to provide comment,
they do so by calling the telephone number
using the access code provided
on the slide that is showing now.
And we'll give it a little bit of wait time,
just in case people are trying to queue up for comment.
Give it a few more seconds before we check in.
Do we have anyone queuing up for public comment?
There is no one signed up for public comment.
All right, so given that there is no public comment,
I'll ask for a motion on consent for items eight through 10.
Do I have a motion?
So moved.
Thank you, do I have a second?
Second.
Thank you very much.
We'll now hold a roll call vote.
Brooks, please call the roll.
Member Rodriguez.
Yes.
Member Petillo-Brownson.
Member McQuillan.
Yes.
Member Orozco-Gonzalez.
Member Olken.
Member Lewis.
Yes.
Vice President Glover-Woods.
Member Escobedo.
Yes.
President Darlene Hammond.
Member Bonacca.
Aye.
Motion carries.
All right.
I want to applaud the expeditiousness of all of us
and our colleagues at the State Department of Education.
We have made it through day one of our board meeting,
and so grab that extra time,
go get a walk or a latte
or whatever strikes your fancy.
We will see you tomorrow at 8.30 a.m.
Thank you.